hello test all right
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for a very special edition of
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast as most of
you know
usually i ramble
and i grace you guys with the brilliance
of my inner thoughts [ __ ] with you um
we have uh a guest on today and this is
a man that i have known
jesus christ i think at least 20 years
uh one of my favorite people out there
in the new york
comedy circuit is that what they call it
he's got a new special out
not new special he's got a um i knew i
was gonna [ __ ] that up he's on the new
uh
tiffany haddish presents presents day
ready season two episode
six the amazing dean edwards
bar what up city look at you look at you
you look great
thanks bro thanks for stressing me you
got a better microphone the windscreen
is it look andrew and i just went
through this i just i
i booked because i'm uh a lot of people
don't know i'm i'm eddie murphy's vocal
double
for all things donkey and uh and i just
booked something ready for me oh you
well you know
you have to understand you know a lot of
people aren't really uh familiar
with with eddie you know and eddie pre
uh shrek pre pre-clumps in the whole
nine
but eddie was a brilliant stand-up man
and and what he's doing now you know
he's not available for everything that
dreamworks has regarding
all things donkey so when it comes to
donkey they said you know what
i worked on shrek the musical for about
two years and then got five right before
we went to uh broadway which was fine
because they jeffrey katzenberg said you
know what i want owen dean i want dean
to be the voice when eddie can't do it
and so it's been like a nice 13
14 year run man and they just we just
yeah yeah man and so we just did uh
something for universal beijing
um you know and uh yes it's just and i
and i told my agent
what my agent said to me about a year
ago you know everything's remote now so
you gotta invest in
new mic equipment i was like whatever
but then when i did this
two weeks ago i said let me let me go
ahead and invest and and sure enough
that
like two days later i booked another
commercial thing
so i needed this at home as opposed to
running through my
look through through the beats by dre
joint you know
no but how great is it now you know the
upside of the pandemic
there's a lot of stuff in this business
where it's like
no one of the advantages of the
uh the pandemic for people like us is
this whole new way
and a lot of people i guess this whole
new way where you don't have to leave
you can just do it like back in the day
i imagine before the pandemic you had to
probably
go into you know into new york city yeah
sit down hi dean would you like a water
yeah
yeah sorry we're running a little bit
late so-and-so was late that's another
thing too like they're late so now
you're late
right your [ __ ] gets pushed back so
that's that's pretty cool man
yeah no dude this has been awesome i
actually um
ev everything anything i've booked over
uh over this has pretty much just been
i've booked commercials through my phone
where i just you know i i
recorded on my on my phone um
and sent in the file the mp3
and they were like yeah that and and
there have been some instances where i
had to go in
um and then there have been others where
you know something like this the thing i
did the commercial i did last week just
patched and there's a there's a site
called source connect
um and and they pretty much just it's
the isdn connection so that
people that are in manhattan connect
with the people with
chicago and myself and they can direct
me
and hear me clearly so yes i'm thinking
like when this stuff
ends which it seems like it's gonna end
soon yeah um
is that uh office space
people are really going to be looking
like wait a minute i can just
you know i we can just you know these
corporate guys be like well why do we
need a studio we'll just have
the artist buy their own studio then we
don't have to even buy microphones all
they need
is one guy in some central thing with
the mixer
how the hell they do it um
i don't know if picking rents rents
might finally go down in manhattan
because they'll have to open up all of
that space
rent has rent went down in in manhattan
but
went up in brooklyn so you know that was
that was the trade-off
people aft i always say because we
lucked out i bought my house
before sex in the city made made
brooklyn
sexy to the rest of america like like
you know people that lived in this yeah
i thought that was still i thought it
was all about manhattan until like the
late 2000s
nah man well i think i think people
slowly came around but i think that was
the
i always say sex in the city is when
people started looking
specifically you saw like white people
that lived in manhattan
that were like no no one goes to
brooklyn and then eventually
after after i don't know miranda
whomever one of
uh section city women once they once
they came to brooklyn
dude if you saw a downtown brooklyn
night right now you would block
i saw it i saw it uh god it was in 2017
i was over there i was doing an episode
of crashing
okay and my i was with my father-in-law
and uh he worked for atlantic records in
like
ben yeah ben he worked for benny hill he
worked for atlantic records in the late
70s
oh wow earlier yeah he went on the road
with like parliament he was on a boat
going around manhattan with like ac dc
when they that's the
rage album yeah and the boat got stuck
he's got all these great stories
but um he was standing on
you know basically near the bridge
brooklyn bridge
and he was just sort of looking at the
boat taxis like
i mean it was like looking at like uh
sometimes when you see like downtown
tokyo all the lights he goes wow this is
just like
they turned this all into disneyland and
they really
they really did because i remember a
long time ago you know i used to do a
lot of gigs and stuff out in
brooklyn and it was like you just went
over the bridge and it was like they
they cut the electricity off
it's immediately dark and you just felt
like man i gotta uh i gotta get my head
on enough
this yeah i would say was was was
was seedy there was a there was a strip
spot there was a strip club called
243 that was right across
uh the the manhattan bridge that as you
got onto flatbush avenue
and i remember because uh because todd
live wrestling please todd was like
hey man hey man tracy morgan he put us
on to this new club
downtown and tracy was like yo dean yo
you gotta go to 243 but don't wear those
sweats
you can't wear any sweats you go you go
in there you gotta let it all hang so
they feel what you're packing
and now that place is condos now
the location where this strip club was
is
this is
poke knock polk knockers whatever it was
and right next door there was a white
castle which i loved
and you would go in there and there was
like bulletproof
glass with the scratch graffiti and it
just looked a dirty fish tank
and there's people in there and you'd be
yelling out in the window no give me six
you know i walked yo add extra pickles
to my my
my white castle yeah man you know what
dare like eat in there it was [ __ ]
filthy oh yeah and everything just had
like those metal things that were pulled
down it was like uh
the hell was that clint eastwood movie
where he drove the bus that he had all
the metal [ __ ] that's
just what it reminded me of and you know
i left new york in like uh
07 and when i came back i couldn't
i couldn't believe it i mean brooklyn is
like amazing but
i know white people always get [ __ ] for
coming in but those are actually the
white people that got squeezed out
they didn't want to leave yeah no no
afford really white [ __ ] right
they come in everybody i got a dirty
look the other day i
i uh live out here in l.a and uh
i got an old pickup truck and uh i had
this guy was fixing it up
and it was in this latino neighborhood
that was just starting to switch over
and you you could just see it's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous how segregated
economically people are yeah
you see like all these like you know
classic like
la houses and then you just see one with
like a fuchsia door
and flowers in the thing like all right
the white person moved it right
it's likely there was a place over there
it was a bread place and had a really
like [ __ ]
pun name right uh just what you needed
yeah oh oh gosh yeah
and i remember standing there going like
oh this would be a good place to take my
wife and as i did it this old latino guy
drove by with his family looking at us
like
and i was just like all right this is
starting to change over
this is not a uh so
i hate seeing that [ __ ] but um tell me
about like what you did when did you
shoot this thing
and and obviously the the uh the tiffany
haddish presents thing
episode six is they ready i got the
whole thing
that that was something that was shot
before or during the panic nah dude we
shot it during
tiffany yeah tiffany called me you're
going to like the story and where we
shot is going to blow your mind because
you're a comedy nut like i'm a comedy
nut
she calls me mid-august and she's like
uh she's like dean
um you ready i'm like for what and she's
like she's like we're shooting season
two
first weekend october october second and
third
so get ready i was like boom so so and i
only i hadn't been on stage since
uh march 15th like everybody else i
hadn't i
hadn't done any zoom shows um i did like
one thing on ig live
which was fun shout out to um ali
siddique but
i just it's too precious and i was i
didn't feel
it felt weird you know sitting in front
of your your computers
but my first date was at acme in uh the
first weekend of uh september a great
club in minneapolis i'm sure you know
and uh i never got past there really
really dude karen i did this too they
when i when i tried to get in there man
they just had beasts
it was like the early 2000s and it was
like you know dana gould margaret
show okay uh uh uh
what's his face uh bob odenkirk would
play there david cross
okay marc maron it was it was pat and
also it was really like like patton i
probably was one of the newer guys
right right he definitely leaned alt
right and i came in there with my uh
greenwich village horseshit
with the with the lean they were like
why are they why are these guys from new
york leaning on their microphones
yeah because we walk everywhere we're
tired
exactly so i always wanted to play that
it never it never
quite worked out and i got a kick out of
one time i saw a female comic who didn't
get in and she was bitching
saying it was like sexism or something
like that i just want to be like you
know just to put your
vagina at ease here that's a really
difficult club to get into it yeah yeah
yeah no anyway so you you did a weekend
out there so i
so i had that weekend lined up and then
i just i hit my agent and said listen
man
we have this thing coming up i need
i need my microphone time i need my reps
and so
they line up some that uh the comedy
connection of rhode island
and uh and helium and oh yeah you see
the green rooms in the bank vault right
yeah yeah yeah i like that club that's
my first time playing that club man
and uh great it used to be brutal when i
first came up the sound was
so f they couldn't because the bank with
the hype so high
right oh yeah oh i had some eyes oh i
had some rough ones in there
to get ready for tv and and helium in uh
in indianapolis was was the weekend
before we shot
and uh and with what uh
the most of the material i was fine with
but i had this whole this my last six
minutes
was this whole sort of uh dc bennett
benny called it a crescendo of
impressions where i just
i had this whole scene drawn out and i
needed to
run that and i was able to get it you
know because
we we all used to tape our sets right
like ian gets on me all the time in
edwards he's like yo
how come everything we used to do
when we first started we stopped doing
when that's what made and i was like
because we started making money
and i gotta i get to do re in one one
sentence
i don't be rude that's it
i don't be rude
when he when he like when he's he sets
something up right right set up the
scenario
and then just be like i don't want to be
rude
and then immediately the crowd's just
like oh [ __ ] what's he going to say
right right that's anyway
that's the passive aggressive jamaican
english uh
seeping out of him that he can't hold
back his tongue
um so i i worked it out man recorded my
sets and i was going back to the hotel
and
listening to everything man and uh and
we
we had to fly out because we shot friday
and saturday so i flew out the sunday
after my weekend in india indianapolis
and just sat in the hotel room for
three or four days before they had to
give us our covet test and then
actually i did you know what i did um
you guys think the all things comedy in
crowd
uh yeah glendale i think that was my
last set
before i shot and so uh godfrey was on
it as well
and uh went out at night because i just
wanted to get a feel for
la right and um and then we
did a million sets with and then
we shot at uh we shot the same place
that richard pryor shot uh
in long beach long beach terrace theater
paris theater yeah i played there
yeah i played this specifically because
of that and it took me like an hour to
figure out how to get in it
you can't you can't see it and like even
like the google map thing couldn't
figure out
right right there it was yeah he shot
that one there and then the live on
sunset strip was the
uh the one right there on like uh argyle
and
sunset uh yeah
how did uh how did it go were you were
you extra nervous
like [ __ ] i'm not a nervous dude but
this was the first time in a long time
that i felt that i felt
super anxious because uh that we taped
two nights and so
on friday night um i was the first comic
right so i was like damn i'm the
sacrificial lamb um
and you know we go out and the audience
is masked the audience is best um
they're socially distanced and we're
shooting out outside
so what um paige hurwitz and and and
pushing productions they built a stage
in the front
of the theater so we only we did like
the talk back we did uh
episode seven of day ready is me
tony woods godfrey barbara carlisle kim
clark aaron jackson
tiffany sitting on stage inside just
all sort of taught just you know doing
what we do like trading stories and
whatnot
but then outside is the stage i go on
first
and uh maybe seven minutes in
i as i go to hit a punch line
a loud motorcycle rolls by
and i'm like i gotta make this so i
trudge on and then another one goes by
and then stage right one of the
spotlights
goes out it's nighttime so
i'm dark so i i said so i pivoted and
said something quickly they gotta laugh
and
just aimed it to stage left and i think
godfrey had to have two helicopters go
by while he was on
but i really believe that stuff happens
almost every set
you just don't notice or care right
right yeah
did you riff about the motorcycle or you
just like i
trudged do the motorcycles i had to riff
about the light man because at that
point
i was like well this is a bust
the second you used the word trudged the
second time i'm like all right dean
didn't like his set
no no all right that was i was pissed i
was
because also i was first and then what
makes you feel a little better
is everybody had something happen during
this set so you're like
okay so i'm not just it's not just me i
don't suck it's just the situation right
the flip side saturday happens i think
it was great similar to how when prior
did uh
live on the sunset strip and the first
night sucked right
but that second night he came out and
blazed a man and so
night number two everybody was on their
a game godfrey went on first instead of
last
he crushed it and everybody just sort of
ran ran the uh
he's actually a great person to put on
first because he has all that experience
all those years hosting at the seller
yeah yeah so he knows how to get him
going so he he used to have to start him
from a dead stop so if there was already
a host tiffany getting him going
right right you can take it to the uh to
the next level
yeah you know what i just heard that
story um
they actually had about richard pryor
bombing the first night
they actually have a framed picture of
the article the review
really the whole weekend and then
richards
was saying how he went out there and for
whatever reason the first night he did
his act backwards
with the he he had i think he had like a
patrice thing
he had to kind of go down first before
he went back
up like oh dude a little
yeah like there was something about like
hey man
the crowd's warmed up and it's going to
be great something like
that yeah certain comics
it makes them want to ruin it yeah so
it's like
you know kind of awful and then like the
pressure's bad gone then at that
i used to have a thing where the only
time i would get nervous if somebody
said it was a great crowd you're gonna
kill
that would make me nervous but if they
said they were awful
and they were terrible i would relax
because it's just like well they're
terrible there's no pressure for me to
do well and then i'm gonna go on stage
and i would do well
and i would actually do worse in front
of crowds that wanted to laugh
like this really frustrating three-year
period of my career
where i would i would get i would get so
[ __ ] nervous
standing on the other side of that uh
particularly saturday nights at the
comic strip the first club i got
past that in new york when you know that
place was just
like so alive on the earth
and there was some kid up there i can't
remember his name they said oh you got
to go on after him
uh you know oh that's uh yeah
i still hate when people do because
because people also have done this so
well now
now we're all you know vets and so it's
no biggie but
nobody wants to hear that no nobody
wants
what's here are you gonna follow a rich
voice or whomever
but i didn't know back then that that
was them projecting their own
[ __ ] right right it's like oh you're
afraid of going up this guy i don't even
know this guy i just got here
but now that you said that now that just
went into my head like oh this guy's
hard to follow
right he wasn't no but you know i
remember the uh he was uh he had like a
cutesy
you know i'm not gonna get into it
you'll know who it is he he
he had after we hang up i wouldn't know
but he probably had
some some his his signature bit
that everybody knew and that was his
that was his oh you don't want to follow
that [ __ ] you know what's funny about
that guy
is uh years later
you know like when somebody gives you
that that that compliment that's really
just a pat on the head and that
they're still putting themselves yeah
yeah i got some [ __ ] gig and he goes
oh yeah i heard you got
that i heard you got that thing i said
oh yeah i did he goes oh congratulations
he's like yeah
that's good for you they said little
that's good for you
i i you know me german irish i never
forgot it of course that when the [ __ ]
did i say you were one of my heroes
the [ __ ] did i say i needed a pat on the
head from you you [ __ ] hack
gugu gaga [ __ ] ugh
yeah i definitely want to do it dude i'm
talking this was like 20 years ago not
25 15.
and uh i i don't ever think about it but
if the name comes up and the face comes
up
i literally say every single time what i
wanted to say in that moment
right of course but you know it's fun
because we always remember
i you know who remembers especially nia
nia remembers everybody who did you
wrong
because she was the cushion that you'd
go because my wife does the same thing
like
people they're people i forgot that i
had a grudge or i was pissed off at
people
and the wives don't forget any of it
because they were with us through that
whole and then he's such an [ __ ] my
wife usually roots for the other person
you know i think he might have a point
and i'd be like why do you always take
this side because you're an [ __ ] and
i'm sorry
all right well not always
no i had a i'm reading this book right
now called the verbally abusive
relationship
and i thought the whole time i was going
to read it i was going to be like
yeah that's you and that's [ __ ] you
and i was reading like oh [ __ ] i do that
well there's another thing that looks
pretty familiar so
that that that was her christmas gift to
you
another comic told me to buy it oh
that's funny and he's good you should
buy it man
you know because i we were just we were
doing a gig together we were just
talking about childhoods it's like jesus
christ dude you have the exact same
childhood i do
i read this book it really helped me out
and i read the book it's really like
helping me out i had to push through
because it was written a long time ago
so it was sort of like
it's just all geared to women getting
verbally abused and there's no sort of
dynamic that that can go the other way
oh interesting uh yeah so i'm just like
oh yeah of course yeah it's always us
right that was me for like the first 40
pages
all right i'm not getting anything out
of this book because i'm getting mad at
the author
right and then so after page 40 that it
was sort of the breakthrough
like i had to kind of go back and reread
it and be like all right that was me
uh going like all right i've done a lot
i don't do
like the people in my life when i grew
up it was
you know 24 7 100 for the most part
me it was just like when uh
i would lose my temper and then
afterwards
she would call me on it and i would just
be like you know defending flipping out
right being like you know what's funny
this like this is how bad i am like she
does preemptive
[ __ ] this is why i'm i'm like trying to
finally fix this
like the way i worked on comedy i really
have to work on this
so we were supposed to go get the
vaccine as they opened it up to people
in show and show business entertainment
right
in front of a crowd you're pulling a
crowd in you know blah blah blah blah
hopefully you know
right so um we call it so my wife goes
hey man i
we got this thing up in northridge which
is way out in the valley
all the way up top up where the [ __ ]
manson family ranch was right
right somewhere up there off the [ __ ]
118. so she's just like all right so
just to let you know so i said oh we can
get it okay great great cool
four o'clock got it i'll be there 4 40.
whatever i'll be there
so she goes all right but just to let
you know there is an outside chance that
they might turn us away
and i'm like i got it i got to turn this
away she goes well if they do sometimes
they have some extra ones laying around
and
they'll give you that when i go all
right cool but she just kept saying that
we weren't going to get it
and then it just got me so [ __ ] i was
just like well then what the [ __ ] are we
going through right
said i'm doing like this [ __ ] right
so then of course we get up there
standing in the [ __ ] disneyland line
right yeah
yeah the sea of humanity just up there a
lot of sweatpants
obese people qualifying and [ __ ] right
right
and uh and we're standing there and uh
and uh uh i don't have my driver's
license
you know some stupid reason but no i've
had the registration on my car so you
can use that too
all right so i would [ __ ] stand in
the line
and of course we get up there and i'm
just and i'm just like i i'm saying i'm
reading the book
do not lose your [ __ ] do not lose your
temper so i go nia why don't you handle
this
i'll just hang back here and i'll just
be like i'm the dopey husband
tell me where to sign so she gets up
there and she's talking
and she's talking and then the lady's
talking and then she's talking i can't
quite hear what's going on you know i
got the masks on and [ __ ] and it just
gets to the point of like oh this
ain't going well why is she talking way
more to these other people and then
so i kind of step in a little more and i
hear that they're turning us down
ugh that we can't [ __ ] get the thing
and blah blah blah
and then i just had to ask
i was just like so let me get this
straight you can make an appointment
you can get an appointment and then you
can come here and still
not be qualified and she goes well yeah
that's because the website doesn't
understand it up here blah blah and i
was like i
interrupted i go don't you think you
should work that out
before people drive all the way up here
i didn't raise my voice i said that then
i quickly thought like they're trying to
vaccinate the entire country
give them some slacks then i just then i
just said you know [ __ ] it who gives a
[ __ ]
and then my wife was mad
was mad at who at the situation she
tried to put it on me she goes why did
you yell at them
i go i didn't yell at him she goes you
were giving him [ __ ] i go
what what the [ __ ] i go that wasn't a
legit question
if i'm not qualified just tell me when
i'm home don't have me drive
40 minutes usually so
and then i was just like ah whatever you
know what i need a new cell phone
charger there's a [ __ ] best buy over
there let's go in there so i went in
and i got something out of it i drove i
drove [ __ ] an hour and a half round
trip to get a [ __ ]
car charger you know what bill that's
called
progress because 10 years ago you might
not have reacted that way
and here's what's funny i'm i'm i'm
calling foul
or or your wife because to me
outside of looking in that seems like
she was
pissed but she couldn't put it on the
woman she had to maintain
her cool so then when you just asked a
simple question
she got to project i had a little
mustard on it when i asked it
okay i went a little
i went a little bit like that right so
so then we got in the car and she tried
to put it on me that i was i wasn't that
mad because i was like [ __ ] i failed
again
you know what i mean full-blown but i
kind of failed again but then we got in
the car and i looked over and i saw look
on his face when we were driving home
and she called a few people and she was
mad and i was looking at her like
look at you i go you're mad yeah i
didn't get that mad
you're a [ __ ] man i just teased you
the whole way home
you know she's my wife's [ __ ] awesome
man we were laughing within the boys
and then what's funny is she went ahead
today and she goes yeah i got an
appointment
to get the vaccine and she got one
without me
and i'm like what the [ __ ]
i'm like now you know how leo leonardo
felt the end of [ __ ] titanic so
you're up on the board now i'm sitting
in the frigid water
so i don't you're about to float away
like they're gonna open it up to
everybody
so if something doesn't happen before
they open it up to everybody
then i'm just gonna wait for that
the same way it did with flat screen tvs
when they first they were like
15 [ __ ] grand right and bobby and all
of them bought them when they bobby that
bottom when it was like they were like
4 000 right five grand something [ __ ]
crazy that happened first
dude no my tv is only this thick
right those things they were huge so
yeah i kept my square tv until like 2008
when i moved out to l.a
right even then i kept it i kept it
until uh
yeah like it kind of became like this
badge of honor that i still had the
phone
that's hilarious watching like matlock
and [ __ ] on it right
so i feel like the fires and all that
johnson johnson's thing is going to be
the same way like there's going to be
this mad rush when people when it first
happens and then eventually you'll just
be able to [ __ ] walk in
get him yeah that's me coming up like a
tank of gas rolling up your sleeves
right stick it in
right you don't even have to stop she's
just literally sitting at the
drive-through that's funny i'm feeling
there's going to be some people that are
going to be like all right i'm too
afraid to get the
vaccine let everybody else get it and
everybody else gets it then it's going
to burn out
and then what's going to happen is
they're going to get it they're going to
get the coven
and they're going to keep it [ __ ]
going and uh to me i always think of
sci-fi movies
i don't know and then it's like the
vaccinated start hunting down
right it's like i am legend that was all
i did uh the premise of i am legend was
someone uh created a cure for
cancer um and then it mutated
and created these these sort of vampire
slash
zombie night walkers and they always
gotta go vampire zombie isn't there
whatever just happened to monsters
they're getting lazy with the makeup
you know what an uglier version of you
rather than these
back in the day straws up your nose and
you had [ __ ] all this hair and [ __ ]
now
it's zombie bill
you know what i just you know it was
funny i just caught myself
i that's the first time anytime i still
call you billy man
and and i thought about back in the day
still does i was
then billy then billy because you know
what happened somebody in boston got in
my head
that just doesn't sound that doesn't
sound right there's no ring to it
really yeah and then i was like so when
i went to new york it's just like
oh my name stinks i do i it like i had
nothing where it was if you if you told
me to change my
name to michael michaelson i would have
done it like when i came to like new
york like i was just like what
and anytime anybody called me like billy
i was just like my parents just called
me this one
i mean i don't mind it or anything like
that but just right right i didn't want
to be known
as that and it took me like three years
to get the courage up to say to a host
just just call me bill
phillips bills like that's how beaten
down was this a kid like i had like
zero self-esteem so now when i hear it
it actually
i like it because it reminds me of this
period in new york that was
uh probably the biggest growth
right in standup when i started doing
like you know sunday night at the boston
and pokemons and all that stuff and
started uh
running into you people
but you know what i got to give you give
you your props man and i always tell
people um i was talking to dc benny
about this um when i had him on my uh
in those rooms he'd be over at nels no
but that that was a thing
y'all were just funny you didn't pander
right
when you would come and do it first at
first i did oh did you
oh i did i did my whole scared to be
doing dance
uh i didn't do that okay
no you know what i used to do i used to
have him play the hardest
[ __ ] hip-hop possible right no no oh
honest john did that whatever they would
always play some [ __ ] rap thing
right right so my thing was that when
they would play because everybody else
would
you know they'd be up there doing all
this [ __ ] i would just come up yeah yeah
cut it cut it cut it cut it jesus
christ and then they immediately would
just be laughing
like right oh all right this is like
archie bunker he's just gonna be
he's gonna be a white dude so i always
told other white comics i go
it's it's all about the first laugh yeah
once you get the first laugh then it's
easy
the the hardest thing is the first lap
once you get the first laugh then you
become like a mascot
quaint the white guy i find this white
guy amusing
getting like extra laughs and then
you're watching all the black comics
have to do almost backflips right
like chuckle and then that's when i went
back to the cellar
okay i would watch black comics go on in
front of you know white crowds
that's why you started making fun of
patrice look at this white lady over
here grabbing her purse it's like put
your [ __ ] pandering just go up and do
your [ __ ]
i feel like a mole on a polar bear's ass
and all of that stuff we
get it right right we get it you're
black right right
i'm missing i miss [ __ ] um
trashing him yeah dude all of that
dude uh i salute to you guys for um
for for the for the killing is easy man
that it
it it was weird watching like von been
killing aziz i was like what the [ __ ]
did we do there
killing is easy killing
is easy enough [ __ ] after one bad date
jesus christ don't [ __ ] take the guy
out my god
oh killing is easy to documentary bed
i enjoyed it because uh vaughn had hit
me and she was like
she was like you know she was she was
real she was like just one i want to let
you know
we wanted to include everyone but we had
to cut your stuff and i was like
van i said i know he was my friend i
don't need
i said it would have been nice i had to
cut so much
so much [ __ ] right so i wasn't tripping
i wasn't tripping like yeah you know
yeah there was a lot of stuff
but but um the whole
all i did on that thing was that it if
mike bonfiglo
is the guy he's the guy that put the
whole thing together
right and vaughn in georgia filled in
all of the
uh him not being a comic type of stuff
yeah
um and then all i did he'd be like
hey can can you do you know this comic
can you can you call him and i would
just
just send him comedians right right uh
mike buck piglet he also did the uh the
30 for 30 the daryl
doc and daryl the one on the 80s yeah
that's yeah so
i knew like when i saw the first rough
cut
and they went all the way back to
teresa's childhood in the pictures
in the buildings and where he grew up i
mean i knew patrice
for like almost 20 years i i was like
riveted and i was just on a rough cut
and i was just like
okay this is great because there was a
couple of um
people going like when they saw the
trailer were you know
saying like this looks like stuff i've
already seen and
i was just like i don't i was like okay
it's gonna once you sit down and watch
it right
like i loved i was talking to dane cook
about like i love patrice's friends from
his neighborhood
yeah yeah dame was like they were like
an old married couple like talking over
each other
and then they ended on the same thing
yeah yeah and
uh and then also to see that he was
the there was that patrice thing even
back then
like yeah talking to women and then
dividing conquering she's bringing your
whole life
down and all of that stuff right right
uh yeah i'm very happy the way uh
that turned out i was talking to
patrice's mom the other day and she's
like
she's like it was wonderful i watched it
like four times and blah blah blah
that's though yeah you you know it
humanized them like like
you know in the in the decades since you
know unfortunately past
um you know i have people asking me
about him
and they they hold him up which is dope
but they hold up the legend
of patrice and you know the whole thing
and his thing i'm like nah he was he was
he was actually a good friend if you
got got the chance if you were fortunate
enough to just
break bread and hang out you know what i
realized about him
a long time i always cut people off
finish that thought no no
no but it was uh it was he was just it
was it was dope to
to that you could see him with a mill
just being a dad just you know just
because i didn't know that stuff
yeah man that was he he called me i was
talking about the shrek thing man
one one of my favorite memories of uh
of him was um when i was working on
you know people started finding out that
i that i was working on shrek the
musical he calls me one day he's like
dean what um yes are you doing this uh
you're doing the uh the shrek thing huh
i said yeah man i said yeah it looks
like
it looks like your boy's gonna be on
broadway he's like yo you know
not for nothing but if you if you
if you can get some tickets for me and
vaughn
and and daughter i said dude i said i
would be honored if y'all came
um that and to me that was just a dope
it was because you're used to walking
into
the the seller and i'm like oh these
weren't
you gotta get on your your college gear
dean's got that
knack of money you know whatever you
stink
i'm like i'm just gonna feel bad for
doing well right right
but that's that's what we did and so it
was just nice
nice the same way i was able to see that
and you were able to see that
in in your your intimate moments where
it was just you and him one-on-one
me and him one-on-one i think the world
got to see that through the uh
through the documentary anyway i thought
that was he was an amazing friend i
realized years after his death
i was watching her old samford and son
that he was doing a little bit of red
fox
you know grady it did
yeah i was like ah i was so upset that i
it took to after he died that i figured
that out i was just thinking
about it oh i could have [ __ ] started
all i would have to do is start that
then keith would have been like oh he's
stealing from red fox and we wouldn't
smash the [ __ ] out of him oh dude
and then he got downstairs and watched
him when he went on when he went on
stage
right well i'm looking forward to
obviously i mean i haven't been i was
you know what's funny i was actually in
new york
when you guys were we're taping the uh
tiffany haddish they ready oh really
yeah yeah yeah that was i was back your
old stomping grounds
huh yeah yeah yeah your old tv show
there i was back
oh right right i texted you man i was
dude
let me tell you something y'all have to
understand i get i just told somebody
this i said
i still get geeked when i see any of my
friends
on tv in movies i'm still the dude
because i'm such a fan of everybody
right
and and i'm such a fan of just seeing us
all win because i remember
like you said being import knockers and
two steps down and these hole in the
wall
you know these these restaurants that
had a tuesday night comedy thing right
remember
[Music]
who those talent hosted that right did
was that yeah
yeah yeah all of those hole in the world
so
so to see when you were doing snl out
it's funny because you must have had a
new phone so i text i was like yo
dude do your thing and i get the text
said
edwards and i said yeah man you like oh
dude thanks thanks a lot man
what happened was i don't use the cloud
okay
i dropped my phone in a toilet oh damn
and that was it and i wasn't gonna go
get it
that's a public toilet i was like ah
[ __ ]
um so uh
yeah so that's how i did so that's
happened to me with a number of people
okay like there's a few people that have
probably texted me
and i didn't know who they were and now
they think that i'm like big league in
them and it's just like
all right right right added technology
so i apologize for that no
no no but you you responded and once you
realized it was me it was it was all
love so
i i don't trip on that stuff i um i i
put a picture up hold up i gotta show
you this
cause you're gonna laugh i put a picture
up of uh i found
on my laptop a picture of when kev's uh
eldest daughter now when heaven was born
and i founded him
found it in my laptop and i was like oh
i gotta post this
if if no i don't have his most current
number but
dude look at this uh this
this is this picture of of little kev
the bastard
oh my god wow
he wasn't the bastard though then he
wasn't the bastard anymore he's
he he was little kev the bastard when
when he was uh
in philly yeah yeah yeah at that point
he was he was in la and so he was just
he was just kev he told him to stop
doing that then he was little kev
and he said like listen just go by your
goddamn name stop with this street [ __ ]
right right
um all right dude it's so good to sort
of see you
yeah hey bro really happy for that and
and uh thanks brother tiffany's such a
great person there too like best man
creating all this stuff for everybody
else to do yeah yeah great so
yeah yeah we we premiered uh uh february
second man is streaming
it's in is streaming in perpetuity on
netflix they ready season two
um you know i'm episode six but but
everybody i mean episode six
night two yeah that's exactly what it
was two i was watching i was like
yeah yeah they just cut all of uh night
one
which was wise which was wise man and uh
yeah man thanks thanks tell tell ben i
said what's up i i just was watching the
old show term at the apollo
uh on on to be like they just run that's
the first time i met nia
seriously august of 2000. we didn't
start dating till like three years right
august of 2000 i was standing
summertime it was all light out and i
was standing in the alley behind the
apollo
listening to somebody getting booed and
i'm like what the [ __ ] am i doing here
and she was there checking people in
right
and he took me up the back fire escape
uh it was hilarious when harlem was
harlem
because i have to write tape right he
walked me to the subway and it was still
broad daylight
you know that's right no you just go
here and you make sure you get the
downtown train
your future father-in-law walked you to
the subway
and i just met my wife and i had no idea
that's
that's wild wow that's
crazy that's that's insane yeah
obviously new york now what kills me is
if
i go up there there's probably some sort
of artisan
cupcake [ __ ] right right where the
hell we were standing there but um
right there's still some some pockets of
harlem that still
feel like like to me harlem still is
more harlem than brooklyn is brooklyn
like brooklyn is
looks like a different city when you're
downtown
but harlem still if you go like 116th
you go to some of the um like frederick
frederick douglass you still
still get a feel of what harlem was yeah
i remember we used to do uh
what the hell was what the hell was that
one up on uh
was it on fifth oh saint nick way up uh
that little jazz bar oh the bartender
sylvia's um ah and i'm thinking
yeah oh my god oh my god yeah i know
exactly one time i did a gig in there
and uh there was that dude um don't say
what club he worked at he was a waiter
okay
his name was okay it was curtis yeah
what's up
yo what's up what's up [ __ ]
well i don't know if he's la i don't
know what he was white latino you didn't
know what he was
right he was he was he was ethnically
ambiguous
but all all the way gay yeah yeah and
drop the n word
every other yes yes he did that words
out there they ain't laughing at [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're just gonna have to
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] n
word n word right
that's a good impression we [ __ ]
we're up there right
in this this uh this little jazz bar
whatever the [ __ ] it's called
and i'm waiting to go on i'm the only
white guy in there and then there's him
and then he's and there's this guy on
stage and he wasn't funny and he was
just going yeah you ain't funny
[ __ ] edward get off the stage
just take that [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
it and he's looking at him
not knowing him being like uh excuse me
uh
sort of light-skinned latino maybe yeah
don't say that [ __ ] word and blah
blah blah
blah and then he goes whatever my [ __ ]
are you a punk ass
right he goes [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
again
and he lean forward he goes yo you a
punk
oh and this dude picked up a [ __ ]
chair
people yeah yeah because it was an older
right right right right yeah all this
[ __ ] happened
and then [ __ ] i'm just sitting there
like
and it's just like coming to the stage
next
this next guy uh comes from a little
further downtown i'm like
and everybody's looking at me of course
well you must be with him
you must be with that guy okay yo
billy let me what about that what smokey
had that room up in uh eastern
uh it was like a lecture hall
that lady threw the shoe at me like
[ __ ] kareem threw it all the way up
and i was leaning forward it almost hit
me in the nuts
and then she was a big woman and she
came down to get it and i was just like
what the [ __ ] is gonna happen here
because i was making fun of her shoe and
sort of hugged it out
and i felt the tension right new york
when
when it was like that yo dude [ __ ] dude
that [ __ ] was all like [ __ ] that was
like
25 blocks away from where i lived just
right completely
different [ __ ] world yeah man once
you cross 96th street it was it was a
different planet
i lived on 97th and lex when i missed
the package
my [ __ ] package would go up to
spanish harlem i'd be like ah [ __ ] i
can't get it now the sun's going down
and i try to get there like nine in the
morning when all the hustlers were
asleep
and i tried to put on my toughest
[ __ ] llb
[ __ ] and i would just walk up the street
you know the
the black knitted thing just not
for just that occasion anytime you had
to go and pick up your packages regrets
was keeping it real and not buying one
of those i was just like i love those
things that i was just
doing i'm already doing the black rooms
i'm gonna be looking like i'm trying too
hard
and he thinks he's aging white yeah bill
yeah
a.g burr he's gonna get a [ __ ]
headband next yo you gonna handle i'll
be all right
i don't wanna i don't wanna yo yo let me
ask you this and
if you ever if you ever feel
i do a monday night i do a monday night
podcast on
instagram live and i've had everybody
from gaff again
yeah i'll do it i'll do it dude i love
just just for this
for that story it's hilarious because
i i did um drew frazier's room manhattan
proper
manhattan proper e to the end jamaica
queens
yeah get out there you know look like
[ __ ] grand theft auto right is
this that glove is literally in the hood
like i am a black man that i would drive
there and before going on stage
i'd have to say to myself i you know
what last time you did i
i think we're gonna be at and then you
get in there and
somebody's you know humping a chair and
talking about roaches i'm like
they don't wanna i remember i went in
there one time and and one crew
got into with another crew it was a
metal detector when you came in
and one crew chased another crew out of
the [ __ ] building
and drew just had the dj playing and
he's doing like the puffy thing that's
right
okay that's right bad boy right and then
and then the second they were out of the
thing and they were just like
all right you all clap it up clap it up
clap it up
come on to the stage and i'm like yeah
not a white guy
can't bring him i think i was out there
with rudy rush and rudy rush was dying
laughing
rudy sitting there like nah you about to
go on next
what do you think this do you think
you'd be high you'd be all right
he's driving home ha ha that laffy head
just [ __ ] laughing at me
i'm gonna go over here dude i gotta i
got some stupid conference call like
eight minutes
uh hi bro so great to see you uh text me
i will my phone now uh okay so
uh let me know when that then that
instagram live thing the next time you
do it
i don't know about this monday but
definitely one of these months no no one
one yeah something in the future all
right bro just gave myself the out
i know about this monday one of these
mondays you took it
i'll definitely do it yo bill much love
brother thanks thanks for having me
all right everybody look for him uh
streaming in perpetuity in perfection
netflix they ready set number two thanks
season two
episode six and follow i am dean edwards
because that's who i am thanks brother
all right thank you dean all right
everybody today's episode of the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast was brought to
you by herb
cider from tim alexander the incredible
drummer from primus
if you love hard cider this is the one
you want to get not only is it
absolutely delicious
you also get my listeners get a 15 off
discount
use the promo code bill bill
at herbscider.com c-i-d-e-r
um oh look who it is everybody indochino
uh discuss how little things or small
gestures can mean
a lot in a relationship yeah the other
day you know what i taught my daughter
how to ride a bike and i was laying
there in bed and my wife said to me she
said hey bill i said hey what she said
you're a really good father
and it made me feel good about myself uh
share an example uh
a love is defined by little things i
just did that with indochino the perfect
custom
wedding suit with every detail
accounted for is more affordable than
you think yeah why are you gonna blow a
bunch of money you're marrying a woman
she's already gonna vacuum it out of
your pocket you need to save it up for
the dumb [ __ ] she's gonna buy
uh share a story of some surprising way
a couple you know has met
or an interesting way they show their
love
oh you know my next-door neighbors are
furbies and uh
recently they bought a pair of raccoon
outfits
you know but that's why how they like to
do it no two love stories are the same
so why where
wear an off-the-rack suit to a wedding
with indochino
a made-to-measure fully custom suit
comes at a more affordable price
uh personal endorsement this is
mandatory talk about your experience
with the product well when you know i
got married
uh evidently i went to indochino even
though they didn't exist yet and boy oh
boy nobody noticed
did you book a virtual st i didn't do
any of this describe your i didn't do
any of this
the best part i should have done this
for the [ __ ] grammys if i knew it was
on the internet
i should have gone to indochino um next
time i get uh if i ever get nominated
for a cable ace award i'll do that all
right the best part indochino suits
started just 299
with all custom customizations included
shop
the wedding collection a book or book of
virtual style
consultation at indochino.com right now
you get 50
off any purchase of 3.99 or more by
using the code bur
at checkout that's 50 off any purchase
of 399
or more at i n d o c h
i n o dot com promo code burr
all right now paulie you know what time
it is
huh oh yeah arch madness
we got sean green and ryan kramer from
monkey night fight our favorite thing to
say here
monkey knife fight the sports gambling
podcast
uh you know i don't want to brag or
anything guys
uh but i kind of crushed it on all of my
super bowl bets
oh i got everything from the coin toss
to the color of the gatorade just saying
yeah as soon as as soon as the blue
gatorade got dumped my twitter
feed got lit up i'm just everyone i told
you
i told you blue gatorade you know burr
had it right
yeah you nailed it man and you were all
over you're all over your buddy brady in
the box and
man that was aggressive paul do you hear
that all over your buddy brady
gonna be that i just knew he was gonna
win it's my buddy now
[Laughter]
all over your buddy baby okay
no i i mean again great job
and again not not coming into the
continent wouldn't i be all over him
he's won
six out of nine now seven out of ten
you're making it seem like i bet some 50
to one horse
i'm with you bill easy money easy money
kramer was on the bucks as well you guys
cleaned up man
i love it i love it what about uh what
about march madness i know we're on the
anything better
uh podcast but verzi anything better
than just watching
a [ __ ] ton of march madness games having
some action actually having the march
madness to talk about
listen i love a favorite and i'm
sticking to it because gonzaga is not
[ __ ] losing
i'm telling you this right now gonzaga
is undefeated they're gonna stay
undefeated
they're the best team in the country i
actually watched him play a little bit
um bill will tell you from experience of
our friendship
and many years of talking sports on the
phone
in hotel rooms in green rooms i can't
lay off a favorite
and if there was ever a favorite that i
had to stick with
it's the [ __ ] it's gonzaga so paul
loves the regular season what happens in
the regular season
in his world is what is going to happen
in the playoffs so if gonzaga beats some
division three team by 80 he
he he lost any i mean i i used to do i
used to drive me nuts back in the day
when he would talk about quarterbacks
that were
better than my buddy brady um
and i'd be like listen if you want
somebody to throw 500 yards in november
against the team that isn't going to
make the playoffs this is your guy but
if you want someone to win in january
i need wins in january so i march is
different
i'm already i i'm not saying i don't
know [ __ ] about college hoop but i can
already tell you just because somebody's
undefeated in the regular season
that that does not carry as much weight
as my striped friend here is trying to
tell you no
i mean yeah gonzaga has looked really
good but you're right
when these teams are undefeating the
regular season it's just so much
pressure leading up to eventually a
letdown game i mean i like gonzaga to
maybe make it to the final four but
to win it all i i think it's a little
crazy i'm going with the team like
michigan
already got a couple tough losses out of
the way
you know now they they know what it's
like to lose they don't want that taste
in their mouth
and gonzaga they just seem to every year
we go through this rhyme with gonzaga
where
they look so good they dominate the
whack and then
tournament time they're in a minimal
security prison
okay if you play on tobacco road or
you're you're in the big ten
i mean that's like you know you got to
make a shank fellas fellas
wire to wire it's over i'm i'm with you
paul actually i think it's not going to
be
it's because it's become
it's becoming popular to find a reason
to pick against
the best team in the country and we've
seen this in every other sport
sean the best team has come home and
raised the trophy at the end of the year
so i think it happens again
uh paul and i are uniting against you
you know what that great
saga coach it's that gonzaga coach's
time okay
that dude has been knocking on the door
for a while he's finally got the team to
do it
um and i saw him playing paul i'm taking
that action
yeah he's not watching looking uh
paul and kramer's actions to win it all
[Music]
i'll take that all day i'll root for him
because i love i would love to see
somebody out of the whack win at all
but like dude you you come on man
this is like yeah you you got bombs
fights here you're undefeated playing a
bunch of who
are they playing out there i i expected
i expected to hear versi
you know being being right there in the
jersey area big east basketball talking
about georgetown
the fact that patrick ewing won it as a
player and as a coach
cinderella's story but you're going
chalk with gonzaga mercy
yeah i mean listen when i watch them
play i the the rebounding the big guys
down there like
and here's the other thing i saw gonzaga
get tested they were getting tested by
uh i think it was byu
byu was testing them byu was beating
them
okay byu yeah byu was beating them
though and byu was beating them pretty
good and people are going oh this is the
game that gonzaga
gives it up and you know what like the
[ __ ]
champions that they are
chanting that at the game paul nothing
scares the whole player when he hears
mormons chanting
like champions the zags [ __ ] want it
like the champions that they are
they [ __ ] came back they went to utah
granted they were playing a bunch of
[ __ ] white kids from byu
but you know they don't get you have a
gig of gonzaga coming up my god this is
crazy
yeah they're gonna win they're talking
about coach k they're gonna win it man
they're gonna win it i'll put [ __ ]
five honey on it what are you doing
i'll take that send that this way buddy
oh wow
you take yeah but so you're taking the
easy way out you're going to just pick
one of 30-something teams
i mean who's going to win any way out
paul is knowing that you're all over it
i'm telling you fade the mush it doesn't
get any
you're pushing the bronx tear up you
think come on kryptonite
come on the huge favorite who won
everything yeah i didn't i'm i'm fading
uh i'm faded just because we were on the
same side in the super bowl and it
didn't work out for us take it the
favorite
bill who do you like any any teams i
know you're not
my team i got three teams that i like
that i root for
michigan kansas and uh
duke so out of the three of the ones who
had the best years michigan
i like their uniforms i'm just kidding i
just i'm like
i'm a housewife here dude i haven't
watched enough uh
i saw some kid on tennessee throw it
down though oh yeah there was
there's some elbows going yeah
they didn't play anybody pale hail to
michigan
yeah 500 bucks off for z yes well i
don't know if you saw bill but uh juwan
howard their coach he was getting into
it i always
i always got to support a team whose
coach isn't afraid to get scrappy
start yelling at the other coach and we
it's it's been hilarious in these
coveted times where the
the the coach is wearing the mask until
he needs to pull it down and yell right
in the mic in the
coat you know in the rest you can almost
you can almost see the droplets
coming out of it you're going to hear my
point and take this virus
that's how mad i am at you it's like why
you didn't wear these masks or the the
coaches who wear the creepy clear mask
it's just so unsettling and they still
again just pull it down
any time they need to yell completely
defeating the purpose
of the mask that happened last night the
knicks had a heartbreaker against the
seventies oh
yes tom thibodeau's [ __ ] mask
was on his chin his shirt was out his
boxer shorts
his [ __ ] boxer shorts were over his
[ __ ] dress
his button down and he just it was like
corona didn't matter anymore it's like
yeah it's like on the call well how do
they make him wear the best if they're
just gonna pull it down to
to yell at these refs interesting little
side notes six of the refs already have
been replaced for march madness
one tested positive and the other six
were went out to lunch for them
bill i know you're not afraid to be a
conspiracy theorist at times
any uh any shenanigans potentially with
the refs here
i just don't there's no upside for it
for college basketball they own those
kids
they don't pay them i think when you get
to the pros
like uh i mean i i think if they were
going to be shaving points or doing
something nuts like that i don't think
that they would get rid of a whole fleet
of referees
i mean it's it's it's a little too
obvious
i don't like it i like the uh there was
only one mobbed up ref
in the nba in the 2000s i love that
tim donaghy was a solo actor no no one
else was involved
donaghy i i listened to some interviews
the guy's hilarious he
he admits to being involved in these
scandals
but he insists that the games he bet on
he didn't
adjust the way he called the game which
is the craziest thing
like he admit that he was involved with
the mob admitted everything else but
tried to still keep some ref integrity
there like dirtbag but i got a line okay
exactly i i just happened to i'm not
[ __ ] kids
so wait a minute though wait a minute
let's real quick bill let's get to this
bet
so you're gonna so 500 i'm putting all
the 500 you're just saying someone's
going to take them out
you're getting a little easier there oh
that's not the kind of that's not that's
not who i am how long have you known me
first of all i'm not taking 500
of your hard-earned money all right so
what are we gonna do
and a cigar okay okay
and before i i before you take your
first bite you have to say
whoever loses have to be like insert
name here
god damn it you were right you've never
been more right in your life and it is
an
honor for me to pick up this check and i
will buy dessert also
i i'm just saying michigan's going to go
further than gonzaga
oh that's that's the best and that's
that's probably even money and and bill
is talking about being married you know
it's a classic married guy thing the bet
is he just wants to hear someone else
say they're right
i can't i i that's as a married guy
that's my fantasy no longer
you know two chicks at the same time
just the wife to go you know what after
all this you were right
moving on i don't want to be heard i
just want to be heard
listen to me sweetheart did you
love me we got some uh we got some
awesome games here again monkey knife
fight
that's the place to go they got college
basketball march madness
tournament bets we got prop bets for
these players again
use that promo code burr get a free five
dollar
uh play and a hundred dollar or a
hundred percent deposit match
up to 50 bucks using the promo code
monkeyknifefight.com
the first four game again there were 64
teams not enough
for all the action had a crowbar four
more teams in
kicking things off thursday night ucla
michigan state
pretty good historic matchup uh you know
two kind of like powerhouses
not great years for either teams ucla
kind of coming in cold
tip off 657 on the east coast we got two
player props
more or less on these points michigan
state forward
aaron henry 16 and a half points kramer
i'll let you kick it off
over under more or less 16 and a half
uh yeah i mean he's he's the nba
prospect too so if you're if you're an
nba guy this guy is going to be playing
in the league and i think if you like
michigan state you like this
you like henry to score over 16 and a
half points shawn as you know
i like ucla in this one so i'm going to
take the under
oh okay you're going under versey what
are you uh where are you at here
michigan state forward
16 and a half points first uh this is
actually the late game
on thursday night getting the tournament
started
you know um i like i like ucla too
so um but so 16 and a half points he's
got he's got to get 17.
yep i'm gonna take the under
okay like it lock it up he's taking the
under
now now he's now he's going anti-chalk
burr what are you doing here over
under sixteen and a half points aaron
henry pretty good forward for michigan
the under then versey said under so i
don't know here i'm with you i'm
i was in my head not knowing you know
who this kid is
hey i got all the unders right of the
super bowl huh
all the unders of the yards that i said
passing from mahomes and brady i got
right when i said the under for the
super bowl
you sound like a community college right
now trying to be number one in something
your niche number one pamphlet school in
the rhode island region
we have the coldest coca-cola in any
cafeteria
the best zucchini valley area the best
pool vending machine
in the break room yes i would say that
i'm thinking this kid who i've never
seen play
who i've already forgotten his name this
is aaron henry
aaron henry i would say that he's
feeling
the pressure normally and he'd be a
little tight on this first game however
these kids grew up with instagram
right they know what it's like to hit
their marks
say it be funny they've had it handled
criticism and all of this crap
everybody's all one and done now
everybody's sick with it i believe is
what the kids say i'm gonna go positive
trip all right just so we have something
to [ __ ] talk about
i'm going i say the kid scores 21. ooh
i like that i'm going over he's he
showed up big
when they played michigan had a nice
game uh ucla's defense is kind of
falling apart and
big ten they actually played their
conference tournament
in this bubble site for the tournament
he's used to the rims
he's not a he's he's dialed in i'm i'm
going over 16 and a half
moving over to the ucla side and i'm i'm
sure i'm going to mispronounce this
guy's name
johnny giuseng uh guard for the
ucla bruins 13 and a half points
more or less paul i know you're on ucla
you going more here
yeah 13. he had that yeah yeah i'm going
to take over i'm going to say he gets
14.
yeah just over all right i'm with you
i'm going over even though i'm on
michigan state for the game lay in two
i do think this is gonna be a little
more high scoring than we're used to for
a uh
for a big ten pac-12 game kramer pac-12
shows up for the tourney the kentucky
transfer has a huge game
goes over scores 30 sean i'm saying he
scores 30.
all right well you can do some uh you
can do some adjusted lines on the monkey
knife fight if you really think he's
going to go off i think they have some
adjusted stuff here and you can add in a
bunch of players and go like
kramer just got me yo you just got me
when you said kentucky transfer i just
literally saw you
here i just saw the bet i'm doing when
you set your touch
so yeah paul perked up he's like are you
talking about a blue blood
program i got nothing to favorite
actually i got nuggets some chalky
action coming your way
bill what about what about you man uh i
think this kid tries to hang for a
little while
don't know who i don't even remember his
name johnny
i write a lot of scripts so here's my
script this kid tries
his kid tries to hang with them in the
first half
he gets about eight i think he can eke
out another six
in the second half but this kid i'm
telling you who's going to rise to the
occasion of michigan state that i've
never heard of
he's go he's going to run away in the
second half i think that that's what
happens they both go over
well and and he's going on that hero's
journey for the uh screenwriters out
there
i i do appreciate bill's honesty of just
saying
i've never heard of this guy but and he
can still hit a talking point
yeah and and just kind of shows you
these talking heads even though they're
pretend
did you see uh the clip of paul pierce
talking about the sixers
and they he would he thought they they
lost by 36
and he was given this whole take on the
highlights and they had won by 36.
she shows you how tuned out some of
these guys are oh dude paul pierce when
you watch him
he's a good dude but that guy just is
[ __ ] checked out man
yeah i think he does the guy who's
phoned in a couple gigs i
i know the look uh when i see it all
right i've never seen a guy give a [ __ ]
less about a post game than paul pierce
ever yeah look man that's like an
astronaut getting excited that someone
else is sitting in
the rocket yeah you tell what's going on
with him right now
you know he's uh making sure there's no
holes in the suit
yeah but give it to the nurse at some
point does anybody care
[Music]
he's already been there he's not gonna
give a [ __ ] all right
florida versus kramer you're virginia
tech hokies right now hokey's laying one
the uh player props we're going to talk
about friday
uh east coast 12 12 15 tip trey mon
the guard for florida his uh his over
under sitting at 17 and a half
kramer i know you're uh you're a hokey
die hard are you are you taking the
under here
listen the former five-star recruit is
starting to show up in a big way uh
after going under this total four
five times in a roshan he's gone over
the last five games
obviously end of the season tournament
time the cameras are bright he's gonna
try to do a lot himself here i think he
goes over
okay he's gonna he's gonna press maybe
but getting a lot of shots up
i think he's finally coming into his own
as they like to say versi
uh florida sec country training
you're going under 17 and a half i'm
with you so i
i think this is gonna be a good game the
spread reflects that
but 18 points against this virginia tech
defense which
isn't amazing but isn't like isn't
bottom barrel i'll say this i think 18's
a lot kramer's the only one
well taking over so i think he gets
there
even if they're down by a lot it's kind
of like the football analogy of the
quarterbacks
either way it's kind of the way they've
been playing so yeah i'm going over
burr where are you at with this one
traymon
i feel like florida's a sunnier state so
you can play basketball year round
so these kids are out there playing
defense and that humidity you get them
inside an air conditioning
they're going to shut this kid down i'm
going under what a relief central air
i like that i like it they're gonna be
running downhill the whole game
yeah it's it's not no humidity in
indianapolis at least not this time of
year i mean we're living in
a very national man it is muggy you got
to adjust the dry heat you know
it's it's dry heat keve aluma
and and again kramer you can correct
there you go 14 and a half points
virginia tech forward i'm going to start
on this guy i'm going
over here again i florida's defense has
kind of fallen apart a little bit late
they've really killed me on some bets so
i'm i'm on virginia tech for the game i
i think aluma getting 15
is doable here graham are you co-signing
completely cosign i'd say
i think the uh the monkey knife fight
folks are fell asleep with the wheel
here his usage has been incredible
lately
i'd be very surprised if he doesn't go
over calling out the
monkey i mean
uh wrong number here he goes over are
you with him versi
i am because he's he's so into the team
and he knows the team
so well he said that he said that with
so much confidence that i'm taking that
yeah yeah you gotta you gotta trust the
guy who's got the inside scooper where
are you at
over under 14. hard to go against ryan's
confidence but
you know the fact that jersey was
enamored by it i just gotta go against
it
i gotta go against it sean by the way i
love how your background looks like a
foot locker the day after christmas
because nobody wanted the eagles jerseys
and everything else was sold
you can call it a foot locker sale but
you can't go out my boy reggie white
minister of defense sorry i'm sorry i
didn't know that was right
no i said rest his soul rest his soul
but that's old school right there
yeah yeah come on that's my entire
childhood i do have a i have a bill
bergy custom jersey on the way
to hang up next to my chuck bed and eric
which uh
you know talking to old school from
bethlehem pennsylvania
yeah my favorite thing i would have been
able to find that was a classic nfl clip
oh yeah we talked about that when you
were calling
oh man he did i shook his hand at a
youth awards banquet and it it looked
like he had
it had gone in like a juicer his his
pinky was like 90 degrees
and he just had this hand he's like oh
my god
yeah ben eric hall of famer all right
last game we're going to get to this one
another should be a classic here
syracuse who a lot of people arguing
maybe not deserving to be in the uh
tournament especially at an 11 seed not
having to play in
going up against san diego state the
aztecs
round one late night uh 6 40 on the
east coast buddy baeheim of course his
dad
is the coach i've been all in on buddy
behind
the kid is just shooting lights out 31
point game against virginia
16 and a half way too low all in buddy
baeheim kramer
you've been making fun of me for my love
affair with buddy mayheim and the
syracuse orange
are you go are you brave enough to go
under at 16 minutes
two true statements buddy is a dog's
name yes
also as a youth coach myself
youth girls soccer if i make the
playoffs like
like we see with jim you bet your ass
i'm playing my kids the entire goddamn
game
so he's going to take all the shots
buddy bam goes over
versi versey where are you at with buddy
beyheim
dude yo this dude kramer i wish you
coached my
you just have the knowledge that if i
like it's like everything you say
i'm just like i think this kid's got his
[ __ ] together like i think that you know
a lot of stuff and i do like the fact
that this kid this is buddy behind's
first tournament or no
no no but this is this is his first
storm at playing
a few minutes he he wasn't he wasn't
getting a ton of action on their on
their previous tournaments that's what
he said i think he goes it's 16 and a
half is a great number but
you know what i think he chucks him up i
think he chucks him up to
you know presses old man and show people
it's uh buddy bayham time
it's i gotta go over 17 points for the
kid
and and that is a i i know you're not a
uh version you're not a gambling tout
but that is a that is right in tool kit
number
one of the gambling tout this is a great
number this is a great number
gives yourself a lot of wiggle room as a
guy who's giving out
a bunch of bad picks if you start out by
complimenting the numbers yeah
give yourself some have no
so they get very impressed when you talk
about the number as if you noticed
oh wow they're very important shout out
to them great job over a monkey knife
fight
burn oh either way
you guys want to see a great gambling
movie watch owning mahoney
i'm trying to get through it it's done
so well as far as philip seymour hoffman
um just the uh oh yeah well i probably
shouldn't say that on a gambling website
so it's a feel-good movie where he uh
he wins every time um all right
but as far as buddy bolham is that his
name bayheim but yeah
let me tell you something buddy there's
only room for one bb in this
entertainment business
and you're looking at them i'm taking
the under i say they shut you down
buddy lock it up go ahead what is the
name of a stock car driver
buddy baker right oh another another bb
it's true that's a real human too i i
thought it was just a dog name
baseball player buddy bell not a
basketball player until he shows up and
scores more than 17 and a half which
will not happen
lock it up on the under and don't worry
most gambling movies end like uncut gems
so it's it's cool it's a
another sunny day movie i i mean you
know that's how you know i have a
problem you watch that movie
not gonna spoil the end but uh kind of a
rough ending
and just leaving the theater i'm like i
gotta figure out how he got that seven
teamer
and i got i gotta get me one of those uh
stones that stone was good luck man
what was that movie with um what was the
movie with pacino and mcconaughey
where mcconaughey was like his guy two
for the money two for the money the
brand
the money the whole point of that movie
was it's basically after all the [ __ ]
they went through
he goes it's a coin toss with the spread
it's literally a coin toss it was one of
the great montages in cinema history of
mcconaughey lifting weights while like
reaching over and picking games against
the spread
it's an all-timer uh as far as hilarious
oh my god that's [ __ ] hilarious well
dude you know you only have abs once in
your life if you're lucky to ever have
them so you might as well show them if
you guys show them if you got them
that's what i say
hey yeah i can't blame the guy god he
got him from all those uh
all those late night bongo sessions matt
mitchell
is the forward for the san diego state
aztecs
15 and a half points ooh
again i'm on cues here to win the game
i'm going under
again maybe i'm blind to just supporting
buddy beyheim because my dog's named
buddy and
and i'm all in but uh i i think they're
their defense a little better than
they're getting credit for cramer
are you over under matt mitchell 15 and
a half points
matt mitchell as you know sean we
adopted san diego state to this podcast
yes so we are
gals i am sticking with that our gals
and matt mitchell
junkyard dog he shows up i think he has
a nice game hits some threes
gets over this 15 and a half point total
versi
where you at kramer's over i'm under you
seem to be team kramer
but uh where are you at matt mitchell 15
and a half
under under okay
i kind of let him as an interviewer
you're not supposed to do this you saw
five reds in a row and he's like i'm
going black
it's good classic roulette strategy uh
all right bill matt mitchell 15 and a
half i know you've been breaking down
his game film
uh in the off season what are you doing
you know san diego state had a
basketball team
football team's been making some noise
and i think that they're uh they're
going to feed off of that
and this kid's going to go over 15 and a
half
should not mind much though because it's
a great number
it's a great number should be noted he
did play well in the simulated march
madness we created last year when march
madness got cancelled so
if that was a a foreshadow any harbinger
for things to come
all right that'll do it for the
tournament talk presented by monkey
knight fight
head over to monkeyknifefight.com daily
fantasy sports for the rest of us use
that promo code burr
get the five dollar game the free play
and a hundred percent deposit jose
go gonzaga yeah
he's on zags uh kramer's on the zags
burr and i are on michigan we'll see how
this shakes
coming down the aisle with this rolled
up program
i'm starting on the winning train i got
a prop for you paul right here
there it is there it is you've been
staying on the winning train i won the
last time you bastard
you're talking about gonzaga train uh
undefeated that's right all right sorry
[Music]
all right guys yeah the guy gets one
gatorade color right it's he's the
[ __ ] king
no no no from coin toss to gate paul if
you did what i did
you would have had [ __ ] jordan ones
with your picks on the side of them the
[ __ ] are you talking about
i really want all right that's it thank
you guys hi guys
sean everybody thank you so much
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
march 18th 2013 how's it going how are
you
i'm upstairs in my half a house at this
point
they got all the demolition done i'm
gonna have to open the [ __ ] window
because it's already too hot in here
this [ __ ] thing needs to be replaced
too anybody want to buy a tree fort
and i think that's what i bought i
bought a tree fort with [ __ ]
wall-to-wall
carpet look at the views if you see the
views
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] everybody told
me you know what
if you ever go to buy a house this is
what i suggest you do walk in there
wearing a helmet
all right with some safety goggles on
put those [ __ ] put the whole ensemble
on and then have one of your biggest
friends just
grab you like a battering ram and slam
you into the wall of the house
and have a look around when you come
when you come to have a look around
you'll be surprised
what you find in there all right if
there's nothing in there
other than the [ __ ] horse [ __ ] you
just broke by all means
make an offer on the house
all right these [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking
[ __ ]
insurance adjusters oh we'll we'll cover
everything
do you know these [ __ ] i had like
[ __ ] wood
in the walls like those slats that they
never have these [ __ ] think they're
going to put plywood
and then they're going to put drywall
over the top of that and i'm just going
to be like oh
that's the same thing isn't it mr bear
we're sorry you didn't have the
premium coverage if you had your premium
coverage and we would have we would have
paid for what you're asking
no you wouldn't have you would have
found some other [ __ ] reason not to
pay me
that's why you're in the big building
isn't it huh
why do you have a pinky ring how did you
get that huh is there some
old woman in in a wet house coat trying
to figure out how to eat her [ __ ]
alpo
is that how you got that [ __ ] ring
you know what's funny is the insurance
adjuster hasn't even come over here yet
and i've already been screaming at the
windshield of my car because i know what
these [ __ ] [ __ ] are gonna do
you know they did it to the entire city
of new orleans they're not gonna do it
to me
you know i'm my own little city here i
don't have any [ __ ] you know there's
no uh
sean penn [ __ ] throwing a boat up to
my house coming to rescue me is there
you know i don't think there is i'm on
my own you know what that's fine
i don't need anybody i've already
resigned myself to the fact
that i am gonna [ __ ] not only restore
this goddamn
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] room sorry
guys
uh i'm in a mood here i am gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna make i'm gonna make it
even better
okay that's what i'm doing i don't give
a [ __ ] if i have to do stand-up gigs
in in and uh i don't know one of those
apartheid countries in front of a
[ __ ] dictator
like beyonce did shaken her [ __ ]
perfectly round ass
on new year's eve you think i'm above
that i'll do i'll do it the [ __ ] day
after thanksgiving
i'll give you a [ __ ] uh two for one
eastern flag day you can have me in a
hawaiian shirt
in whatever [ __ ] compound you're
living in to keep the people from
storming the damn thing because you made
a deal with the cia and you gave away
the [ __ ] oil didn't you i'll come
down there i'll do my acting you [ __ ]
foyer
all right i'm gonna get some of that
blood money i'm gonna get some of that
blood money and i'm gonna [ __ ]
restore this goddamn
room back to the way it was supposed to
be
you know because that's what the [ __ ]
i've been doing i've been sitting here
for the last [ __ ] couple of days and
i've been finding out
where all the goddamn stuff is that i
need have i cursed enough i really gotta
take this down a notch don't i
or does it make you feel better about
yourself he swears me more than i do
[ __ ] and i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i never i never passed nothing you know
you meet somebody and they're like you
know i was good at math but i wasn't too
good in history
well i like i was good in history but i
wasn't good with that woodworking stuff
[ __ ] right i'm one of them [ __ ]
when a few [ __ ]
i ain't good at [ __ ] i sucked from the
second i
pulled into the parking lot [ __ ] she
called my name and i forget what
the [ __ ] she was talking about you know
and if he
she just feel like lenny and i feel like
just sitting there
you know just sitting there wondering
why my deck was hard
you know um
am i having a nervous breakdown oh
christ
so i was looking i forgot to look this
[ __ ] up god damn it
so i've been looking up all these old
houses that they have out here in los
angeles by the way specifically
the pasadena area has these amazing
houses out there
um and i've just been looking up how
people went about restoring them
okay now if they were able to [ __ ]
restore an entire goddamn
um house that i there has to be enough
[ __ ] left for me to do a room right
please tell me that
i just sounded like fast eddie and
[ __ ] uh
reservoir dogs please tell me somebody's
got the diamonds okay can somebody just
please [ __ ] tell me so anyways i
started looking up all these houses
right
this is back you know back in the day i
i'm a big fan of [ __ ] blue blood
money
when there was a name attached to it you
know back in the day like people
knew the names of the rich [ __ ] that
were stealing from them
they knew what they looked like they
knew where they lived
it was unreal
the vanderbilts the asters the
rockefellers
the rothschilds you know and then you
had the people who started uh
you know like like procter and gamble
that wasn't just a name those were
[ __ ] people
like there's a house out in pasadena
called the gamble house
it was made by these guys green and
green and they they did those uh
what do you call them uh uh what do you
call craftsman american craftsman's
houses
so they would build a house for and
everybody how much money do you think
procter and gamble have you drive by
well there's the gamble house right
there
that's gamble's house what does [ __ ]
proctors look like you know johnson and
johnson all those goddamn families
so anyways i was looking these things up
and there's this house out in pasadena
called the blacker house the robert r
blacker house
and uh what oh come on you [ __ ]
i can't you know something how dumb i am
i can't even click on something
hang on a second here let me click on
this [ __ ] the blacker house out in
pasadena
you can't believe what happened this
house is [ __ ] unbelievable actually
drove by it the other day like a goddamn
stalker
looking at it and
this house was made i guess for this guy
robert and nelly blacker right so
typical you know
rich people they get this unfucking
believable house
you know built at the turn of the last
century so it's all this wood
you know they're cutting down like
[ __ ] 150 200 year old trees or
whatever so the shit's solid is a rock
you know as opposed to that [ __ ]
[ __ ] they got down at home depot you
know
[ __ ] shit's grown down in el salvador
by some [ __ ] eight-year-old
you know once the tree's taller than the
kid they make the kids saw it down
four in the morning before they make
them [ __ ] plan another one start
watering it you know you never realize
that that's how trees grow now
eight-year-olds they teach them how to
sleep on their feet
they sleep like standing up and they sit
there like just slowly watering them all
night and then it causes them to grow
faster it's a whole it's a whole uh
i saw it in 60 minutes you guys should
check it out if you get a chance if you
got a hulu
you might want to look that up but
anyways so they made this amazing house
and all the furniture and all the [ __ ]
in it
and the chandeliers and all of that are
basically worth a small
fortune now so what happened is of
course the [ __ ] lady
outlives the guy why because when [ __ ]
hits the fan
women cry and guys [ __ ] deal with it
that's why bang there it is did the bell
go off in your head that's the first
sexist moronic thing that i'm gonna say
well not first moronic but the first
moronically sexist thing that i'm gonna
say in this [ __ ] podcast
all right when the [ __ ] hits the fan
the ladies they [ __ ] cry
that's what they do the guys we're
crying on the inside we got to hold that
[ __ ] together as we push an ikea couch
under the [ __ ] waterfall that's
coming through the top of your house
that's that's what we do
they go oh my god it's ruining
everything
and they get it out we don't
so hence 35 [ __ ] years later we drop
of a heart attack while we're mowing the
lawn
because in the middle of our chest yeah
it's ruining everything
is still [ __ ] in there attached to
oh my god the car isn't getting stuck
all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
is just one big [ __ ] ball sitting
there
right on top of your hat and then that's
it you [ __ ] keel over
and then she has the nerve to stand
there going i told him to stop eating
red meat i
told him to have a salad he didn't like
it he said that food was for the queen
um anyways so this [ __ ] house
this [ __ ] house um
they kept everything like all original
right up until the 40s so that stuff was
already 40 years old they already
weren't making furniture
well maybe in the 40s they kind of still
will but the style had changed so if you
walked into that house
in mid like 1945 when this woman died
it was like stepping back in time like
45 years like you ever go into an old
person's house and see their stereo if
they kept it in immaculate immaculate
condition
the car they're driving their [ __ ]
can opener
well maybe not now but back in the day
in an old can opener you know
be made of some real [ __ ] materials
instead of some plastic hunk of [ __ ]
right they had all that stuff and they
had all those beautiful sconces and the
chandeliers and all that stuff on on
on on the walls and on the ceiling
everything right
so anyways in the wild the lady
says whoever buys this house it's it's
all encompassing you have to buy the
house it comes with all the furniture
they had it look what looks like another
house behind it that was just for for
visitors like a mother-in-law suite
looked like a [ __ ]
four-bedroom colonial that was the guest
house that's how big this [ __ ] house
was
they had a greenhouse they had this
giant property so when you went in and
bought it
after she died the person had to buy
everything and wasn't allowed to sell
off anything
so of course she dies and then the
[ __ ] greedy [ __ ] what do they do
they sell the house and then that person
immediately divides it up
sells off the mother-in-law suite gets
rid of the greenhouse cuts up the
[ __ ] property
has an infamous [ __ ] yard sale
and sells all of this unbelievable
furniture
and to this day it's in museums and uh
private collectors own the [ __ ]
gets even worse what happened to this
[ __ ] house that's what makes you feel
better about me because i only lost one
room
this beautiful [ __ ] house with all
this [ __ ] they already lost all the
furniture right
but they still have to the the windows
and the chandeliers and all that [ __ ]
some [ __ ] buys it in 1985
who's a [ __ ] deals in like vintage
chandeliers and all this stuff
he buys the house for a million bucks
guts the [ __ ] thing
is selling these chandeliers for like
six figures to who
i don't know but somehow he's selling
him for like 150 200 grand
he's selling the sconces for like a
hundred grand he guts the [ __ ] place
replaces everything
with a home depot replica piece of [ __ ]
was called the rape
of the of the [ __ ] blacker house or
whatever i'm reading all of this stuff
is this boring to you guys i don't know
what
so i've been reading up on all of this
[ __ ] but whatever somebody bought the
house after was able to restore it
painstakingly i might add painstakingly
so i figure if these guys can do that
you know i i can restore this one
[ __ ] run they're already trying to
pull this [ __ ] on me telling me that
people don't put plaster up anymore
it's like yeah they do i just had my
[ __ ] rooms out there replasted i
already have a guy i write your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
with your plywood and your drywall is
that what you're gonna do then why don't
i just do it
why don't i just [ __ ] do it because
you'd [ __ ] it up bill yeah but you know
what i could do most of it
around the windows would be a little bit
difficult because it requires some
[ __ ] measurements
um so anyways that has been uh
that's been my week and
i got a bunch of [ __ ] i have to do
tomorrow right so that's why i'm doing
the podcast here sunday afternoon
so anyways i walk in the living room the
lovely nia is watching one of her
reality shows
and you know it's these five just
toxic women sitting in this limousine
and one of these women is telling this
hap one of these women who's divorced is
telling this happily married woman
that she needs to speak up to her
husband more and it was basically
because the husband
said i'm old-fashioned because i'm an
old-fashioned guy so he's out there
killing it
making an insane [ __ ] living right
and she's the little homemaker
right so [ __ ] mc divorce steen right
[ __ ] divorce dean there you go is
sitting in the back of the limo
and basically telling the girl who's
[ __ ] she's got the best deal ever
she married somebody who's out there
making a [ __ ] load of money
and all she's got to do is keep the
house together
that's all you gotta do you got all
[ __ ] day
jesus christ how long does it take to
sweep the kitchen
you know you can even hire a [ __ ]
cleaning company
just have the [ __ ] clean and when i come
home have dinner ready
for the life of me for the life of me i
don't know why
certain people look at that as slavery
you know unless look if you have some
[ __ ] dream
you know and you have ideas and that
type of thing you want to go out and
pursue them
by all means but if you're just gonna be
another cog in the wheel
taking the [ __ ] subway to work to go
make somebody else's dream come true
you know what i mean why the [ __ ] would
you take that other thing
you got all day to get out of the house
go for a [ __ ] walk
you know
[Laughter]
dude i swear to god in another life
if i'm a [ __ ] stay-at-home mother i
swear
to [ __ ] god i am gonna i'm gonna get
[ __ ] season tickets
to everything to [ __ ] all four sports
and i'm gonna knock out everything i
have to do during the day
i'm gonna have that [ __ ] dinner ready
the second the dude comes in
and then when it's over see ya i'm out
[ __ ] running down the thing on my
[ __ ] heels and i'll go to the goddamn
game
i don't know what they're complaining
about
you couldn't have more [ __ ] free time
you know even when you have kids it's
you're still running [ __ ]
you're still the boss you know
i don't know i don't know i've talked
about this [ __ ] so she ends up telling
this
this this lady in the [ __ ] back of
this limo
she's like you know that's all well and
good if he wants to [ __ ] blah blah
blah
but you know that old-fashioned stuff
can also be controlling
it can also be control it can you know
people when people are dumb
is when they make one point and they
have to say it three times in a [ __ ]
row
to make it sound like they made a bunch
of different points
but they only made one and now it's not
working
and now it's not working and now is that
[ __ ] you just want to slap him on the
side of the head it's like are you stuck
in there
what's wrong with you i heard you the
first time i heard you the first time
she's [ __ ] driving me
[ __ ] nuts with this [ __ ] and then she
ends it with you know so if he wants a
sandwich
he should go out there and have to make
it himself and i just uh
oh that whole [ __ ] [ __ ] i i women
like that are always like you're not the
king
you're not the king but then two seconds
later if you were to say
you're a queen they would 100 agree with
you
and it's that classic [ __ ] i think i did
it in one of my stand-up
things my stand-up skittles i swear to
[ __ ] god
every goddamn thing that they [ __ ]
about that they do not want to be done
to them
they will [ __ ] do to you in a second
if you let them
all right this is why me and nia can't
watch tv together because
she watches the dumb horror channel
and she watches it to laugh at the dumb
horse which
if i was a woman i could sit there and
laugh at the dumb horse because at no
point
would i be financially like
connect you know i mean like the biggest
fear
for me anyways is you're going to
[ __ ] get married the girl's going to
flip on you and then take everything you
got there's nothing you can [ __ ] do
about it
right so when i watch those stupid
[ __ ] that's what i see i see a limo
full of child support just [ __ ]
lazy get your [ __ ] life together
losers
decked out by the way they were on their
way to a titty bar
okay you know so right there everybody
in the if
everybody in the car is [ __ ] suspect
it's like wait what what the
[ __ ] how old are you i don't even go to
teddy bars anymore
but christ think ladies get your
middle-aged [ __ ] back in the [ __ ]
house
and make a goddamn sandwich am i right
you know bad i want to go on like ellen
degeneres's show and somehow get half of
that out
just to see how long how much of it i
could get out
before i don't know before somebody what
through the morning after pill at me i'm
a vile of that [ __ ] right at my
giant forehead um
anyways i was just thinking what if my
hitting me in the forehead was a
carnival
game what what do you think you would
win it would be so [ __ ] easy my
forehead's so goddamn big
you know you'd win one of those remember
those little koalas that
you could stick on the end of your
pencil back in the 70s i'm sure they got
a box of those left over somewhere
that's what you'd win
until they ran out so anyways this is
the monday morning podcast everybody
it's ignorant it's sexist and uh
it's great for kids we got some
advertising everybody we only got one
this week
oh we only got one strap yourselves in
here we go stamps.com everybody a quick
trip to the post office is hardly ever
quick
driving there finding parking you know
trying to get there before they close
right you go to stick it in the air in
the mailbox you freak out has everything
got the stamps on it and all
that crap right it's a hassle
so do what i do use stamps.com instead
stamps.com is quick
and easy is the quick and easy way to
get postage on demand for any business
buy and print official us postage for
any letter or package using your own
computer and printer
stamps.com will even send you a digital
scale that calculates the exact
postage you need for any class of mail
you don't need one of those expensive
postage meters
and you'll never waste valuable time
making trips to the post office again
endorsement this is me everybody
iustamps.com to send my dvds out to my
wonderful stand-up gigs i have never had
a problem
it's phenomenal i've done it in my
underwear
i've done it with no shirt on wearing my
my uh my little jeans or something right
looking like i'm gonna be on the cover
of some teen beat magazine like the
the sensation joe derosa try stamps.com
today right now use my last name bur
b-u-r-r for a special offer no risk
trial
plus 110 dollar bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage they're giving you
55 bucks
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in burr burr
that's stamps.com
enter burr all right back to the podcast
back to the podcast um did you guys
watch the uh the ufc fight
um gsp versus nick diaz i believe his
name was nick
i i go in and out of watching the ufc i
i
i love it i love the ufc i love boxing i
love all that stuff it's just that all
the pay-per-views
are saturday night am i right this
saturday night and i'm usually doing
shows
and uh and i miss them i always end up
missing them
and um but every once in a while what
happens is
like i used to watch it on the versus
network all the time
and uh i don't give a [ __ ] you know what
level ufc that is it's two people
trying to beat the [ __ ] out of each
other that are way better fighting than
i am like i'm not going to watch that
what am i going to watch five [ __ ] in
the back of a limo on the way to a titty
bar
talking about how they don't make a
[ __ ] sandwich
you know well then get your ass on the
stage sweetheart oh that's the third
sexist moronic one um
oh god that [ __ ] that girl really
annoyed me
that woman was happy she was making
sandwiches and this girl is such a
[ __ ] negative [ __ ]
it's not enough that she's [ __ ] up her
own relationship she has to
[ __ ] this girl's relationship and ruin
this guy's he's gonna he's
he's gonna come home and be like what
the [ __ ] happened everything was going
great
and then she's gonna come at him with an
attitude you know not bringing two
nickels into the [ __ ] relationship
you know i don't know all right let's
let's
let's just let it go bill let's just
[ __ ] let it go
i mean i don't know maybe maybe she's
making millions on her reality show
um i can tell you right now they
probably make less than comedians
[Laughter]
let me ask you this people when was the
last time you bought a box set
um of a reality show i don't think they
exist
that's why they're like disposable
that's like the bic
lighter of [ __ ] television shows um
it doesn't have any legs you know
so they pay you once pay once and they
pay us [ __ ] money uh you know what good
and i'm glad they're all getting [ __ ]
spending all their money on [ __ ] mani
pedis
jesus christ is this am i really that
upset about a reality show or is it the
fact that half of my house is [ __ ]
gutted right now
i couldn't even say house i have my
house anyways
so every once in a while this is the
thing for me i am a sucker for a boxing
or a ufc
promo you know when they get on there
and they do the background they show
both the fighters working out
and they start telling their stories and
everything that they have on the line
and how they need
i swear to god if i start watching one
of those [ __ ] things
i'm ordering the fight to the point like
i avoid them i avoid them because so
many times you [ __ ] order them
and then the fight sucks you know it
doesn't live up to
the hype you know especially with boxing
jesus [ __ ] christ
jesus christ i've spent more [ __ ]
money on
all the way back to the tyson era the
tyson ones were always worth
their money even though he'd knock him
out in [ __ ] 90 seconds it was still
like you were watching some babe ruth
[ __ ] you knew it
you know then we went into the lennox
lewis years and
it just got all [ __ ] up even half the
oscar de la hoya once towards the end i
got [ __ ] on those
you know and then they always got that
great white hope coming in
you know and they show them i i d heidi
honey heidi
heidi who right he's skipping rope and
he's got an angry [ __ ] look on his
face you look at him going this guy
kicked the [ __ ] out of me right and then
the black guy's all confident like man
he's wearing that [ __ ] and
you're like you know what i'm going to
order this [ __ ] and what comes out
already
and that's it it's [ __ ] over it's
[ __ ] over
you knew he wasn't fast enough you knew
he was too slow you knew it but they got
you
they [ __ ] hyped the [ __ ] up and the
[ __ ] dude sat there not only did he
beat his ass he did a little dance
mocking him and then
he just knocked him the [ __ ] out that's
what happens every goddamn time right
but i still order him so the ufc thing
like
you're up see championship
so i [ __ ] watch i'm watching dana
white on there
right and dana white comes to the podium
and i'm going bill
don't watch this [ __ ] promo do not
watch this promo
because the second you're done watching
this you're gonna take 50 60 bucks
whatever it is
and it's going out the window but there
was something about the look on dana
white's face i'm like i got to watch
this [ __ ]
and it comes to the mic you know just
the mic and he's just like
gsp snapped
today it is the most angry
i've ever seen him he said nick diaz
is the most disrespectful human being on
the planet
and he is going to absolutely destroy
him something like that
okay and i'm thinking like gsp this
guy's like [ __ ] he's like captain
america
he never gets mad at anybody he doesn't
let anybody get under his skin
he [ __ ] stays he's like a robot
he just [ __ ] goes in and does what
he's got to do he's made him that man
and then i see this nick diaz guy
and he just look he just looks the part
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] you up
and it was just the two worlds the guy
who spikes the football
and the guy who just hands it to the
referee colliding
i gotta see this [ __ ] i want to see what
a
furious [ __ ] gsp looks like and i
want to see if this other guy
can actually back up all this [ __ ]
talking so i order the [ __ ] fight
it ends up being a great fight i'm not
saying
that i got [ __ ] in this fight at all
it's totally worth it and the fight
before it was great
with that dude from texas with the heavy
hands and the [ __ ] ulysses s grant
beard
loved it okay but this is what pissed me
off at the [ __ ] end of it and made me
feel
stupid was in the end you know
rogan's uh interviewing the guy
and then they went and he was going you
know he seemed like he got really angry
and blah blah blah blah blah
and then he just goes uh you know and i
was waiting for him to be like saying
like this guy is a piece of [ __ ] and i'm
glad i [ __ ] beat him
and i was waiting for him to finally see
that side of him and he just goes uh
gsp just like i did not take anything he
said personally
he was a great fighter he did a great
job uh promoting the fight
everybody give him a round of applause
he is he has to stay as a good guy
it's like wait a minute i thought you
snapped
i thought you did take it personal am i
that [ __ ] stupid i felt like a
[ __ ] idiot
i did not take it personally
it's like george however you say his
name
the whole reason i [ __ ] ordered the
fight was because i thought you took it
personally
i'm an idiot i'm like charlie brown
trying to kick the football
i fall for it every [ __ ] time now
maybe it's because he won
or maybe because he's so aware of his
his image
that he just didn't let on that the guy
annoyed the [ __ ] out of him but there's
[ __ ] sitting there
holding each other's arms up ah man you
know
and it's just i don't know he absolutely
snapped today fast forward i did not
take it personally he is a great guy
come over here uh we are gonna go play
shuffleboard now
he's a great guy he's a good competitor
and uh
and then the other guy's going like hey
i think i'm done with the uh
mma i've done you know i'm sick of this
i don't know what to do now and then
george is in the background
no no no stick with it yoga yo yo
you can come back he's like giving him
words of encouragement
i don't know am i an idiot but
that [ __ ] annoyed me don't [ __ ]
tell me
this guy's taking it personally and then
i ordered the fight and the [ __ ] guy
said he wasn't
it's false advertising
i'm just [ __ ] around it was a great
fight but you know what i mean
don't look i know they're just selling
the fight but don't [ __ ] tell me
that
everything we said up until this point
was [ __ ]
i'm actually friends with him and his
wife we go down to applebee's every
other day
we do not take a puzzle um
whatever it was still a great fight and
uh you know i got to keep saying that in
case i [ __ ] run into one of those
guys
and they headbutt me with their [ __ ]
cauliflower ear like their ears even
their ears are tough you know
every time i watch a ufc event you know
what it is
it's the [ __ ] kicks that's what kills
me as amazing as it is to watch somebody
who's on the bottom getting [ __ ]
taken elbows
to their head and and [ __ ]
actually looking over at the clock like
17 more seconds of this
i can handle it maybe if i bring my
bloody forehead closer to his chest
um he will only maybe graze the back of
my head and you know i have fresh skin
back there that hasn't been broken wide
open at this point like the level of
toughness that that is
that that's a whole nother level but
when they're just standing up
and the [ __ ] one dude just kicks the
other dude right where you'd get a
charlie horse
and they just take it that [ __ ] blows
like how do you get that tough
dude i'll tell you right now if i was
standing in line
at a [ __ ] grocery store and some
eight-year-old i had pants on
and some eight-year-old came up to me
and just [ __ ] whacked me
punch me ah maybe not a punch i could
take a punch from an eight-year-old
all right let's let's move it up here a
[ __ ] an eight-year-old whose dad is
like six
nine so the kid's already five [ __ ]
four
i'm just saying any if you ever want to
just [ __ ] knock me down
you don't have to be all fancy and hit
me in the judge just hit me in the leg
right there i will crumple
like the [ __ ] plaster in the ceiling
in my office
um everything just goes back to that
doesn't it
um what else what else can we talk about
here how do we talk hockey did anybody
watch the bruins pens game
penguins game they put on a [ __ ]
forechecking clinic
they uh they were amazing they look
great and the fact that
geno isn't even back yet was uh was
pretty scary
i mean we have a great defense so we
were able to keep it two to one but it
felt like it was more like
three three one like a back in the day
three one
when three one was like the tipping
point because then if you went down by
three goals it was [ __ ] over there
was no way you were coming back
then they got rid of the red line and
then you know within a minute it's like
a thai [ __ ] score
but um they look great and crosby is
without a doubt the best player in the
[ __ ] league
it's insane that [ __ ] line that they
have
is terrifying and uh the only thing i'd
say is they're maybe they're goaltending
i guess
they're starting to play better but i
don't know about their goaltending
i don't know either way either way they
beat us again
we finally beat the capitals that was
cool but we we're we're missing
a crosby level now nobody's at crosby's
level but you know
we need a [ __ ] 50 potential 50 goal
scoring guy
um we need we need a next level guy we
got a defense
that's all good we got the goaltending
that's all good but like this whole [ __ ]
where we're gonna score two [ __ ]
goals a game
and try to stop these upper echelon
teams it's it's not working
it's not [ __ ] weird you know what's
great did anybody watch the capitals
game course you did
did you see when that that dude was it
henderson or something got kicked out
whatever the [ __ ] his name is he gets
kicked out of the game
and some boston bruins fan is screaming
down at him to the point the guy
stops and starts yelling back at him you
gotta see
i gotta oh did i erase i think i erased
it
if anybody's got a copy of it it's a
fight
about with like five minutes left in the
game and one of the capitals gets taken
off the ice oh is it the end of the
second period oh [ __ ] all you know is
you got to see the bouncer
the security guy who's in in like the
tunnel
and he [ __ ] comes walking out and
just clears day he starts pointing at
the bruins fan
and he goes hey shut your [ __ ] mouth
shut your [ __ ] and then they they cut
it
[Laughter]
i love it i love seeing the highlights
of where i'm from and seeing the
behavior hasn't changed it makes me feel
smarter
um all right let's get to some um
emails for the week now a lot of you
guys always ask me i always forget to
say you know if you want to email the
podcast you want to ask me questions you
want to trash me you want to do whatever
the hell you want to do
uh it's bill at the mm podcast
dot com bill at the capital m capital m
capital p oddcast dot com
um all right army wife relocation
hey there bill uh i hope your house is
feeling better thank you
um it's actually it's been gutted
it's been gutted at this point that's
where we're at
um i hope your house is feeling better i
am an army wife currently
living in butt [ __ ] burg cans ass
we are stationed at fort riley until
july this year when my sweetheart
heads over heads on over to afghanistan
my conundrum is where should i move when
he leaves because i sure as hell
ain't staying here by myself at any
moment i heard a fat dirty pajam bottom
wearing walmart
shoppers with black bottom feet jesus
can you paint a picture
um said could lynch me for being brown
and under 300 pounds
[Laughter]
i gotta get out of here and thankfully i
am fortunate to have two choices of
where to go and therein lies the reason
that i need your assistance
um i could move back to seattle where i
lived two years ago
it's all true about seattle by the way
beautiful clean
white depressing rainy better than
kansas or i could go to fort lauderdale
florida
where i have never lived but i just
visited last week it's a little scary
because i haven't
driven like a complete [ __ ] with
crystal meth throwing through my
veins so i don't know if i can handle
myself on the road
but aside from that it's got just as
much going on
going for me there is seattle and it's
not [ __ ] kansas
uh i think that with all your travels
you must have some
insight that you could really you could
relay
loudly to me through your podcast um if
i well personally
i would pick seattle over fort
lauderdale florida any day of the
[ __ ] week
the people are smarter um
you don't have the hurricanes
like florida is like a destination state
for dirt bags
you know what i mean it's it's one of
those like
la's a destination city for people like
me
you know i'm going to be a movie star
whatever dumb [ __ ] we want to do right
so we come out here you know and then
[ __ ] about how flaky everybody is and
when the reality is it's
us you know we're the ones coming out
here
and we don't we're not personally
invested nobody's invested
in this [ __ ] city um because you
always think i'm gonna make my money
then i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
um that's and everybody's trying to make
their money so they're always looking
over everybody's shoulder
trying to see the next person coming in
the [ __ ] room and uh
while they say everybody out here is
flaky but anyways getting back to what
you were talking about i would go to
i mean seattle seattle's [ __ ]
beautiful i know it rains i know it's
[ __ ] depressing but
um fort lauderdale
i don't know man i mean
the fact that it's like and don't let
people go down there for spring break
do you want that for like one month of
your year
you know waking up in the morning
hearing show your kids
show your tits do you want to do you
don't want to do that
you know you got [ __ ] hurricanes
there's alligators
they got mosquitoes the size of my
[ __ ] head
um i don't know
i mean you understand all i do is i fly
in and i do a [ __ ] gig
down near like the strip mall area and
like
i don't know i like the tampa bay
lightning
and i like the devil race
i don't know like florida is is is is
kind of like
sunny kansas in a way you kind of still
got the gun culture
you kind of still got the walmart people
um i'm not saying they're all like that
you know what i mean
i mean tiger woods lives there right
shaq has a place down there's some
zillionaires down then you got you got
the [ __ ] all the movie stars living
down there in miami but fort lauderdale
um i don't know that's safe to say
because i don't [ __ ] play there and i
play seattle so i think i made a smart
business move there
personally i would move to seattle
yeah [ __ ] that move to seattle go down
to the fish market get yourself a
[ __ ]
clam sandwich whatever the [ __ ] you do i
don't know
you know i don't know i don't [ __ ]
know you you got like
on the other opposite ends of the
spectrum listen were you unbelievably
depressed
if it's cloudy [ __ ] nine months out
of the year then i wouldn't move there
but i'm just letting you know
i saw a t-shirt one of the few really
truly funny t-shirts when i was in
florida it said florida
a sunny place for shady people you know
it's kind of like you know
florida is the sunny alaska i guess is
what i should call it
where there's a lot of people in alaska
who have some unfinished
business down here in the lower 48 if
you know what i mean
wink wink little slap of the nose there
all right
there's a lot of people uh running from
things
you know
if the skaters don't get them then the
gators will
what [ __ ] song was that that just
popped in my head
hang down your head tom dooley was that
the one
hang down your head and cry
oh boy you're bound to die that's funny
back then you could have like a hit song
just talking about somebody
who killed the woman and then got hung i
met her on the mountain
blah blah blah blah blah better on the
mountain
stabbed her with my knife
hang down your head tom dooley
that's a song about a guy hang down your
head you know like i'm supposed to feel
bad for tom dooley it's like you [ __ ]
killed you killed your girlfriend
go [ __ ] yourself tom um all right
addicted to vagina
the next one everybody how's it going
there billy boy
i'm 22 year old college student
you're not addicted to vagina you're a
22 year old college student you're doing
what you should be doing you don't have
an addiction
all right uh you're sewing your oats
whatever the [ __ ] they say um i've been
seeing this girl for a while nothing
serious but we've been hooking up on and
off for about a year all right so you
got a side piece
nothing wrong with that um she's
incredible looking
where the hell am i she has the natural
body of a playboy model
she's the kind of girl who doesn't need
makeup
you're gonna keep saying the same thing
over and over again i'm jealous you son
of a [ __ ]
um she has long blonde hair and she's
the most
amazing [ __ ] that can possibly exist oh
this is the curse of a guy however i
want to [ __ ] somebody else right
she's ferocious in bed
what if she growl at your balls
easy lady easy
and for some reason she thinks we're in
the same league
he goes but i hate her i hate everything
about her every contrived opinion that
falls out of her soft perfect lips every
shitty band she tries to get me to
listen to
every unfunny air quote joke she insists
on repeating over and over and over
every going to nowhere story she spends
five hours telling me i
hate her oh my god
but i just keep agreeing to s to see her
i've manned up and stopped replying to
her text messages a few times now and
blocked her on facebook
but before long she'll send me a text
about some nonsense
the blood will start rushing to my [ __ ]
and all of a sudden
i'm standing next to her again it's like
a compulsion
i feel like a heroin addict i get laid
but [ __ ] other girls just feels like
drinking non-alcoholic beer at this
point
can i just stop saying a lot of you guys
are really good writers like that kansas
one was really written really well this
was great
like i would should be in reader's
digest they would [ __ ] you know
loosen the belt a little
um anyways what do i do man up
and suppress my instincts throw her out
the bedroom window or quit cold turkey
um i never miss the podcast we'd love to
go see you do a gig in ireland go [ __ ]
yourself
um what do you do
uh uh you know what
i was i've never been able to solve that
problem
you know because unless you just jerked
off
you know she's going to text you and
it's just going to it's going to be a
layup
and she's g guys can't say no to layup
[ __ ] we just can't
you know unless we're like head over
heels in love
and like i guess yeah when you meet the
right one then you can say no but you
know what it still pisses you off
[ __ ] annoys you you know why
because like when you're with the person
you're supposed to be with and then
somebody throws you a little something
and it could [ __ ] happen and you
don't
[ __ ] do it you come home and you want
to get credit for it
and women go why should you get credit
for something that you should be doing
and it's like you know what go
[ __ ] yourself because go [ __ ] yourself
that's why
because you're not me you're not a guy
and we are
literally we're designed
to [ __ ] be weak so we will [ __ ] you
so we could get out of the cave so we
could [ __ ] progress
so we would procreate we i we are wired
wired to [ __ ]
this is such a moronic [ __ ] podcast i
love it
um all right so what should you do
all right well ultimately in life what
do you want to be married to
the woman in your dreams or some girl
who's ferocious in bed
oh and but you [ __ ] can't stand
everything that comes out of her mouth
you got to get rid of this girl all
right
it's not going to get any better you did
it a zillion times
all right you you got to go cold turkey
you got to cut her off
all right because what's going to happen
is if you stay with her and then you end
up [ __ ] getting feelings for her she
might [ __ ] you over
and you never loved her to begin with or
you get married to her and then
then the [ __ ] looks go away and then
you just with this [ __ ] idiot who
can't tell a joke can't tell stories
and listens to shitty music and
eventually uh you're gonna pull a fill
specter
that's what i'm gonna you know your
hair's gonna be all over the place
you're gonna stick a gun in your mouth
it's gonna be horrible
you don't to do that all right
i would um what is hard though is you're
saying she's so good in bed that it
makes all the other girls seem like
non-alcoholic beer
well you know that's one of the
that's one of the dangers of going out
and living life
is uh people who never leave their
hometown they just [ __ ] stay there
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
missing so they can actually in a way
you know live a happier existence
just by not [ __ ] knowing the fact is
now
you know you know a level of uh
of banging that you didn't know before
ah jesus christ yeah
yeah you know uh you're in trouble sir
i can tell you this you know just
standing outside of it listening to it
you got to get rid of her you can't
stand her just get rid of her you're
just [ __ ] her eventually
those tits are going to [ __ ] sag um
but that was that mouth's still going to
work
okay and when she's not blowing you
she's going to be telling you awful
stories so you know what you need to do
um so there you go i would just man
up and get rid of it and it's like i
know the longer you get away from it
you know here's a great thing you know
what
i don't know next time you [ __ ] rub
one out think of her immediately
afterwards
all right and that's gonna be your true
[ __ ] feeling about her
all right
facebook messages hey dear billy i need
your help dealing with the girlfriend
issue
i have been seeing my lady since
december
i'm 30 and she is 27. that's a good
[ __ ] age difference i like it
she lived in the city and i lived in the
country we started as a long-distance
relationship but it got serious quickly
and now she has moved back home um
she's what is this [ __ ] green acres
she is busy buying her own house but has
stayed with me for the last two weeks
we've talked about me moving in with her
we tell each other i love you and we're
making plans for the future etc etc
so today i log onto my computer and her
facebook page is still logged in
uh oh this is a whole new world man
the facebook thing uh me being a curious
creep i started snooping
in the message section i find a
conversation she's had with the former
boyfriend
on february 1st she tells the guy i
still miss your face
done it's over
walk away walk away
like de niro and he just [ __ ] get up
and walk out
it's over i don't need i don't even need
to read the rest of this sir
it is [ __ ] over but i'll keep reading
it
just because i have to fill up an hour
here but i know
you know the people listening know um
anyways he goes i don't see any response
from the guy
then on february february 11th she
trolls out another message
i love how now you're stalking her
facebook page as well you should
you had probable cause you never did no
you were you were a creep
and then you found you know what this
wouldn't stand up in court because you
didn't have a warrant
but you know what you got instinct and
you can't teach that
um anyways
she trolls out another message that say
hope all is well
and again no response yeah dude she's
settling for you i hate to tell you that
but she's settling for you
what she's trying to do is is if this
[ __ ] goes
you know i miss your face too she's out
all right but if he doesn't he doesn't
get back to her
she's gonna settle for you
okay and i'm not saying you're a bad
person i'm just saying the feeling isn't
there
she's settling for you which means the
entire time in your [ __ ] marriage
every time you're not looking at her
she's just going to be staring at the
back of your head
looking at your dumb shoulder something
just going like
how the [ __ ] did i end up with how did i
[ __ ] that other one up
you know you don't want to be that you
got to get somebody's crazy about you
anyways here we go there were some
previous somewhat explicit messages they
sent back and forth before we got
together
and messages about how they should text
instead of facebook
all that being said she is good all that
being said
however everybody she is good to me
i'm good to her and we have fun a fun
loving relationship
i had solid trust and now i'm very
confused
how should i approach her with this
i know if i keep it to myself it's going
to fester and really piss me off
would you head for the hills immediately
or give the relationship a chance thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself this is what i
would do
i would be 100 honest with her
say listen i gotta be honest with you uh
what the [ __ ] is today
the 18th about a month and a half ago i
went to use the computer
and your facebook page was open and
even though i shouldn't have looked i
did look and then she's going to start
crying
and she's going to start [ __ ] she's
going to turn her [ __ ] cap around
backwards and get in your face and start
screaming and yell blah blah blah blah
[ __ ] all of that [ __ ] all of that she's
going to come at you like that
because she knows what's coming all
right
and don't get mad don't take the [ __ ]
bait
this is the time sir you have to hang on
to your [ __ ] emotions she's gonna cry
or she's gonna yell or she's gonna do
both because she knows what the
how could you still well you didn't
trust me anyways
you know and you don't have the line
that they they have where they just you
know female intuition
they they get to hide behind that you
know like like guys don't have any
[ __ ] instincts
like we weren't blessed with any of that
you know [ __ ]
chasing down saber-toothed tigers with
sharpened sticks like we weren't we
weren't blessed with any sort of
instinct give me a [ __ ] break
all right so anyway she's going to cry
or she's going to yell or she's going to
do [ __ ] both
and you just stand there and you let her
do it
all right and when she's done yelling
and crying or whatever the [ __ ] it is
just say yeah
and i saw a message that you wrote to an
old boyfriend saying
i still miss your face
you know and then you tried to contact
him again
on the 11th and it's been bugging me and
i didn't want to bring this up to you
because i didn't want to look like a
creep and i didn't want to hurt your
feelings
that i don't trust you but um
you obviously still have feelings for
this person
and i guess you're settling for me like
if this guy doesn't get back to you then
you're going to move forward with and
settle for me and that's not what
i want i want someone who's crazy about
me and doesn't have other issues
you you seem to have unresolved stuff
with this guy
and uh you know i'm not getting anything
any younger so
you know and then she said yeah break it
up with me
then all this [ __ ] and just keep going
listen
um there's a face that you miss
sweetheart and it's not mine
you know sir take your heart
and stick it on the [ __ ] nightstand
and go into your brain
all right get some self-esteem here
this is [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
all that being said she's good to me
she's not good to you
not a hundred percent all right
i'm telling you get out of it get out of
it
[ __ ] that all right did i make myself
clear
all right next one ufos dude my question
is in here somewhere oh for
[ __ ] sakes i gotta read all of this
brace yourselves everybody dude did i
tell you guys i [ __ ] got on the
goddamn scale
and i'm 185. i was all the way down to
170 pounds i [ __ ]
i was too skinny then i should have been
like 172 that's my fighting weight
i put on i put on 13 [ __ ] pounds
i think you know you know what's the
dumbest thing you can do
is when you don't want to get on the
scale you're like i should get on the
scale go no don't because i don't want
to know
that you're just signing yourself off to
another [ __ ] 10 [ __ ] pounds
i had a waffle witch in wisconsin what
the [ __ ] was i thinking
i was on that crack again i was hitting
the pipe i was doing the sugar salt
[ __ ] arm wrestle
you know so now i gotta i gotta go i
gotta go run the [ __ ] stairs now
i did that to myself because i ate a
[ __ ] waffle witch
in grand rapids [ __ ] with uh michigan
uh i wasn't just a waffle witch i had
mcdonald's twice
you know why did i have mcdonald's i
don't know
i don't know why i did i went drives
like you know i
had one of those in a while and i
[ __ ] you know hit the pipe again
had that i started drinking miller high
life in a [ __ ] can
they had the talls right down the street
and it became like this ritual i watch a
hockey game i
throw back at all you know hey
maybe i made it up too next thing i'm
having one a period
and then i'm looking down on my stomach
and i'm going like
really come on this isn't i'm all right
i had a banana for breakfast
right i'm fine [ __ ] my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
ate a piece of cake yesterday i had
green frosting what the [ __ ] is wrong
with me
what am i doing you know
when am i going to bottom out so i
bottomed out so now i'm back
i'm down to about a buck 82. i've
dropped like a couple two or three
pounds
and uh you know ah let's [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm more
you know i'm like i'm like bill clinton
before the heart attack up and down up
and down with the [ __ ] weight
all right ufos dude my question is in
here somewhere
i am nowhere near a conspiracy freak or
anything like that but i do admit i get
a hard-on for any documentary on that
secret
military base in nevada that is called
area 51.
the government is supposed well i mean
believing in aliens
like i i don't know
that that's really not that crazy
you know you think like how big the
[ __ ]
universe is there's just life on one
planet
no life anywhere else despite the fact
that they see evidence of water on mars
at some point you know i'm telling you
guys we're not that special
if you're god and you made the whole
universe are you i'm just gonna sit back
watching one [ __ ]
planet maybe that's why the earth is so
[ __ ] up i don't think he's been
watching us for the last couple thousand
was the last time he reached out
reach out reach out and freak someone
out
all right when's the last time he
[ __ ] did that was the last time he
[ __ ] was in a burning bush going hey
hey you there you there with the long
[ __ ] curvy stick next to the sheep
come over here come over to the burning
bush you know once last time he did that
i think he's been watching other earths
um flipping through the channels
you know can you imagine how clear his
[ __ ]
how big do you think god's flat screen
tv is how clear
is that picture i bet even if you make
it to heaven
you know you don't even get to see it
like he comes out of his office and you
try to peek in real quick
and like the human eye you get just it's
just too much of a [ __ ] glare right
um so anyways yeah if you believe in
aliens i mean
i mean i don't know that that we can
reach one another
you know that whole flying saucer
[ __ ] horseshit
i mean how long can you go with with
artificial
breathe you know some sort of atmosphere
in there
that was like on star trek i mean they
just had this limitless supply of
[ __ ] oxygen
[Music]
just [ __ ] flying through space
they now look at them they landed on a
lot of planets that had oxygen they
would just land on these planets and
they just had oxygen i think what they
did was
they opened they landed the starship
enterprise they just opened the windows
and they got some more oxygen and then
they flew away right isn't that how it
works
anyways the government supposedly is
housing
and researching crashed ufos and uses
deadly force
to keep regular people out do you have
any opinion on the subject i think i
just said
i mean i don't [ __ ] do i think they
actually have the bodies of aliens
um
do you realize like the level of secrecy
you would have to have if you actually
had that [ __ ] that would be like one of
the things before they went in the room
it's like okay
we're gonna let you in this room and
you gotta understand when you go in this
room the door is closing and you're
never getting out
because you're going to see some [ __ ]
[ __ ] in here that i don't give a [ __ ]
you're not if you have one shot of
nyquil
you're going to be blabbering about it
you can't do it so i i don't know
i don't [ __ ] know um anyways he goes
what does your [ __ ] meter say i
think there's way too much of a veil of
secrecy around the place to think
otherwise
i used to know someone who was a career
air force pilot whenever the subject of
that base or
those mysterious flights mysterious
lights over phoenix
scene in 1997 came up he completely
removed himself from the conversation
uh those mysterious lights i don't even
know what you're talking about for all
you know they're just
testing some psycho [ __ ] weaponry
you know really when the new yankee
stadium came out
in like 08 or 09 and they were like we
have 2013 technology
all right if those [ __ ] morons that
run that place
can have [ __ ] that we're not gonna have
you know they can be four or five years
ahead of us
can you imagine what the government is i
mean
they gotta have [ __ ] from like i don't
know 2014. i i have no [ __ ] idea
i don't know anyways he says uh quite
frankly
the evening's laughs would end right
after the topic was brought up
i believe in life outside of our
universe to think that we human and all
of earth's inhabited so the only life
anywhere is just plain ignorant i 100
agree with that
uh i'm sure you've heard stories about
president nixon
secretly showing ufos and aliens to his
favorite comedian jackie gleason
uh that's a complete crock of [ __ ] uh
what would you
like he's gonna do that all right now i
know i'm not supposed to show you the i
know i'm not supposed to throw yourself
and away we go that was a bad nixon
impression right there
um what would happen if you were shown
some stuff like that i
imagine i would immediately be
microchipped or shot in the back of the
[ __ ] head
would you tell about it i wouldn't want
to know about that
that if i actually found out about that
it would blow my [ __ ] mind
i you know what it is look maybe that
maybe your air force guy
buddy there has seen something because i
would say that like all converse
no but you know what he laughs right up
until that moment
if he wasn't laughing at all throughout
all your conversation
then i would i would believe it more
because i know if i knew some [ __ ] like
that
and then i would sit there and listening
to people talking about god and holy
[ __ ] that we believe down here
that didn't include aliens i would i
would feel like a [ __ ] alien
because i would be like uh yeah we're
just a speck of dust bear people
and there's all this other stuff out
there and uh
yeah it would drive me nuts after a
while
um yeah no i'm not cut out for that
[ __ ] uh
the kind of secrets i can keep are like
uh
you know you know it stays in the locker
room kind of [ __ ]
you know what i mean you live your life
i you want to [ __ ] live your life
you know and until like if you're uh
look if you're pouring [ __ ] into the
water supply
you know if you're doing stuff like that
if you're [ __ ] vandalizing
the neighborhood i live in then go [ __ ]
yourself all right but you know
the other [ __ ] i look the other way
but if i knew there was [ __ ] aliens
yeah no this look i'm too [ __ ] stupid
there's no way they would tell it to me
if i was in the air force how far into
the air force you think i would get do
you think i'd get anywhere beyond the
guy with the two sticks guiding the
[ __ ] plane
in you know
i don't know anyways he says blackhawks
first bruins for the 2013 stanley cup
hawks and fives maybe six uh
i don't see us making the stanley cup
finals i hate to say that unless we
make a trade i know we're looking for
alfredson but i don't know who we're
going to give up for
but uh i saw a gap
between us and the
the pittsburgh penguins i'd be
interested to see
how those or some of the other teams
i'm going to start watching the penguins
i'm waiting to see when they play uh the
canadians because i want to see if the
canadians are as good as their record
because they're [ __ ] killing it right
now they really are
um oh by the way that almost made me
stop rooting for gsp
when the crowd started going oh lay ol
and the only thing that saved me was he
had the quebec nordique [ __ ] tattoo
on the back of his cap
so i'm like alright this guy [ __ ] he
likes the avalanche
all right belinsky many times you've
said we're all doomed because of
overpopulation but it's actually the
opposite
we are doomed because people are not
having enough children
oh geez
okay from uh
oh jesus did you join a culture
all right you know what i'll go along
with this the following article
discusses
what i'm talking about we'll put this
link up on the podcast page for
everybody to read
essentially america's fertility rate is
declining meaning the population will
get older and older
as it also shrinks meaning more health
care costs and fewer reasons for
businesses to
innovate and provide better products
also
global population growth is slowing to a
halt and will begin to shrink within 60
years
i don't know where you're getting your
stats from sir but uh
okay low fertility societies don't
innovate because their
incentives for consumptions
tilt overwhelmingly toward health care
they don't invest
aggressively because the average age
skewing higher in capital shifts to
preserving
sir are you addressing are you ever
going to address what the environment
you're going to address what we've done
to the environment or are you one of
those people who believes that seven
billion people on this planet
okay and that horseshit out there in the
pacific ocean
that's [ __ ] two and a half times the
size of texas and two miles deep
that swirling pile of trash out there
we put a [ __ ] hole in the ozone layer
okay less people
as far as for the survival of humanity
okay [ __ ] all selling widgets and all of
that horseshit and oh well everybody's
gonna be on the iron lung
if we don't have any babies um
a bunch of people need to die
they need to die off there's way too
many [ __ ] people
there's only so much fresh water there's
only so much natural resources
there's only so much fish you can pull
out of the ocean
there's only so much [ __ ] [ __ ] you
can throw in the ocean
before there's that tipping point
tipping point
um what you're sending me sir is not
facts what you're sending me is an angle
this is this guy's and i will read this
angle
okay but
what i love is that someone has written
that that you know
um overpopulation you're like many times
you said that we're all doing because of
overpopulation but it's actually the
opposite
what because this guy says so so the
other smart people that read the
wrote those other studies they're
immediately all full of [ __ ]
because this other guy said this you
know
did you read the [ __ ] that i read
because i'll read your thing
but um i think the problem is
is that human beings will never stop
believing that we're we're [ __ ]
important
and that we're made in god's image and
all that other [ __ ] ego maniac
[ __ ] that eventually causes you to have
[ __ ] eight kids and go out and buy
two flat screen [ __ ] tvs
the solution sir is not more people okay
i mean think about it
were we doomed back in the day a
thousand years ago what was the world
population then
were we doomed we somehow survived
how are we not going to survive sir
because of these health care costs
we have a national debt that we're never
going to [ __ ] pay
we're still all going to work every day
people still have apples in their mouths
when they want them
i don't understand what the [ __ ] you're
saying
the greatest thing that could happen for
the possible i believe
for the survival of humanity is if there
was
way less of us way [ __ ] less
way way way [ __ ] less all right if
you somehow were able to weed out
sociopaths along the [ __ ] way
and selfish [ __ ] i think if you just
weeded out sociopaths and selfish [ __ ]
you'd have the right number on this
planet
and i think it would be under seven
figures
whatever sir i'm just [ __ ] with you
i'll read your your
i read your [ __ ] you know but don't come
at me like you [ __ ] know what you're
talking about any more than i do because
you read some stupid article
all right um
i love how it's all based around
business low fertility societies don't
innovate because their incentives for
consumptions tilt overwhelmingly towards
healthcare
uh i don't i don't i just in
philosophy i just don't believe in it
whatsoever
all right but i am a [ __ ] but i think
i'm smarter than you because i can admit
that
all right that's the podcast for this
week everybody uh as always if you'd
like to donate to this podcast just go
to the amazon link
on my uh podcast page billboard.com
click on the podcast page you just click
on the amazon link if you want to buy
something
it'll take you right to amazon doesn't
add any money they kick me a little bit
of money for whatever you buy and then i
take the ten percent of that and i send
it on to the
wounded warriors project and uh that's
it that's the podcast for this week go
[ __ ] yourselves and i will uh hopefully
this time next week
i will find myself uh somebody knows how
to put together my house the way it used
to be if anybody lives in the los
angeles area and has lived through this
[ __ ] and wanted to restore the wood and
everything to the way it was
and you know know of a contractor or
somebody please uh
send me an email bill at the
mmpodcast.com
look me up on twitter facebook anything
reach out to me
i am i'm open to all suggestions and i
really appreciate everybody who's helped
me
so far to steer me in the right
direction it means a lot to me all right
go [ __ ] yourselves we'll talk to you
next week